a couple days ago
there were a bunch of conservatives
trump supporters typically a right-wing
group of protesters
in oregon the governor had convened a
meeting i believe it was the governor
but it was
at the state capitol building and these
this right-wing group came out
because they have a legal right to
attend a public hearing
we do we are a government for oven by
the people so
if there's gonna be a public hearing you
walk in the building and you listen to
what they're saying
most people don't know this too you can
go to you can go to dc you can go into
the capital build like the congress uh
building the senate buildings
you can walk around and walk into a
congress person's office just open the
door and walk right in
well these trump supporters these
conservatives they show up
and what ends up happening there's a row
of police telling them they can't
actually come in
at some point i guess cass ensued and
the most
interesting thing about all of it was
that
the trump supporting group someone in
this group bear maced the cops
now that's something you don't even
really see all that often from antifa
and so this story is from a couple days
ago and i just find it absolutely
fascinating with everything going on and
more importantly
that we have this coronavirus spending
bill 900 billion dollars
the total omnibus spending bill was like
2.3 which included this
and it's famously providing 10 million
dollars to pakistan for gender programs
that's exactly what the american people
have been begging for
with where their tax dollars would go in
an unprecedented crisis where their
businesses have been completely and
totally destroyed
and that's why i'm bringing these two
stories together and bringing up this
protest from the past few days
to see right wing groups attack police
in any capacity
tells you that the wick
or the line of powder leading to that
powder keg has been lit
and conservatives aren't going to be
taking all that much longer seeing trump
supporters start criticizing police
and mock them instead of defend them
when they when you hear defund the
police
well that's interesting the
establishment needed at least that level
of support from trump supporters
so we're gonna talk about all this we'll
talk about a lot of stuff going on with
the cove hypocrisy dr burks
retiring because she's violating her own
lockdowns it is hypocrisy all the way
down
we have an awesome guest sean parnell's
hanging out
you want to explain something some
people are listening so they can't hear
they can't see you oh i thought there
was like a camera and stuff and people
were looking
well i'm i'm here i'm excited to be here
you know i'm excited to be here
definitely definitely i've been watching
your journey
you know and watching verizon trying to
get the internet hooked up yeah that's
been a saga in and of itself
right but been impossible yeah we live
in we live in very very strange times
uh you know the the attacks in in oregon
were something that we haven't seen
before
uh you know tim we were talking a little
bit before the show
i feel i feel bad for for the police
because i feel like they've been put in
an impossible situation
uh you know the police in pennsylvania
though
uh one of the things that that i've been
advocating for uh
for for quite some time now uh and i say
it over and over when i'm out
is that government derives its power
from the consent of the governed and
what i've been saying
uh both publicly and on social media for
for some time now
is that we simply need to disobey
these unconstitutional lockdowns in
other words keep your small business
open non-violent civil disobedience keep
your restaurant
open and if you're a police officer that
finds yourself in a tough position
uh and boy anytime they put a gun on
their hip and they wear a bad they wear
that badge on their chest anytime they
leave their family they put themselves
out there for us
every day and they deserve our gratitude
for that but if you're if
you're a cop and you're put in a tough
position to shut down
a small business or close a restaurant
simply don't
obey an unconstitutional water indeed
when you're in the military
you know people think that soldiers just
obey every command that's given down to
them no you we have a duty and
obligation
to disobey orders that are not moral
right or that violate the constitution
and so
what i've been calling for in
pennsylvania is civil disobedience from
small businesses
and restaurants and the police you know
state troopers
sheriffs local municipal cops just
simply disobey unconstitutional orders
and all of this ends tomorrow it's done
and so
but tim this does not mean that we're
not going to take
this that kovid seriously this does not
mean that we're not going to follow cdc
guidelines this does not mean that we're
not going to protect the vulnerable
no no not that what i'm talking about is
entirely separate
what i i believe that we should trust
people uh we we should put faith and
trust in people to assess
what level of risk is tolerable for them
right and respect their individual
rights absolutely
we we we are not a country of kings or
of a king
we this is a country founded upon the
idea that the individual
would choose what's best and their
rights must be respected absolutely
for those that don't know who sean is uh
how would you describe yourself
you're a politician you're uh oh don't
say that about me
don't say that oh man every time someone
calls me a politician i throw up in my
mouth a little bit but
um yeah but you ran for office so you're
a politician i did i'm just messing with
them
yeah i ran i ran for office even though
it wasn't my idea
uh president trump called me out
randomly at a speech in western
pennsylvania to run
before that i was uh doing charity work
i i was a small part of a charity that
gives service dogs
to veterans who come home from war uh
poured myself into that
did 35 to 50 public events a year all
over the country giving away dogs
it's kind of an amazing thing to behold
because dogs really do provide
tangible healing value to people who've
suffered greatly from ptsd
uh whether it's in the military or
remember that guy you're talking about
he uh he was a journalist and he went to
a range and
yes he fired the ar-15 and then claimed
he got ptsd
maybe we should get him like a pug or a
terrier or something
some little small lap dog pomeranian
make him feel better yeah
yeah we're gonna put him on the list
and so but i also i also write uh i
write books i write stories and before i
before i um uh jumped into politics and
this this crazy war that we're in
political war that we're in
i was in hollywood trying to sell
screenplays and stories for for books i
mean
and so uh it was medically retired good
luck now
yeah as a republican yeah i know i know
you know there are good
there are good people in hollywood there
are there are good producers or good
writers that that sort of believe the
same things that we do
uh and before any of that before i was i
was an infantryman in the army
uh went to ranger school went to
airborne school uh and then went to
afghanistan for
16 months of heavy combat longest combat
deployment in global war and terror
history
uh where 85 percent of my men were
wounded some twice
i think one dude was wounded three times
six of my troops weren't even citizens
of this country
uh when they served northerners serving
next to southerners black next to white
christians next to atheists i mean we
had we were the most diverse infantry
platoon that you could possibly imagine
and it was my job as a 24 year old kid
to sort of be the platoon leader even
though
as a platoon leader you're not really in
charge of anything you know
i had non-commissioned officers and
soldiers who were probably
30 30 years old 40 years old who had a
heck of a lot more experience than i did
um some of whom had multiple combat
deployments so
what i tried to do as a young leader was
just you know show up at my unit
you know i had i had the cool sexy
schools that the army required of a
position of platoon leader in the light
infantry
but just have big eyes big ears be
humble self-effacing and just listen to
those experienced non-commissioned
officers who are the real door kickers
uh
in combat and let them teach coach and
mentor me
on what they thought was uh a servant
leader and so that's sort of been
what i've been doing my entire life i
don't know if you wanted an answer as in
depth as that's very basic yeah i
basically gave you the whole
my whole life one thing i've said often
is that probably the biggest
factor if i'm looking at a politician to
vote for is if they served in the
military and
whatever brand should you know some kind
of service that surprised you really
that's that's important to you
absolutely and even as somebody who grew
up in chicago
uh yeah i think growing up in chicago
actually brought me to that but
i come from a military family for the
most part you know i didn't know my dad
was a marine my grandpa was a marine
world war two he trained dogs
uh my brother was in the army my sister
you know
she married somebody in the army that
was a while ago though tim do you want
to know why i think it's important from
you know i i look at you know whether
you're a democrat republican independent
if you've served in the military it
means that you
at some point in time in your life you
put your country before yourself
you put your country before your family
you put your country before
uh your own life or making a buck uh and
something about that the idea of putting
your country
first not for money either not for money
no i mean not for money
you put your country first you take that
oath and again whether you're a democrat
or republican the hope is is that you
know should you win
some political office and you find
yourself in washington that
you can work with the other side you can
put your country first and
do what's best on behalf of the people
which is why
this you know this covid this coveted
relief bill
i think was just it just did such a
disservice i have issues with this bill
on
let's let's we'll save it because we're
supposed to be just doing the intro but
it was getting good
i don't know i don't i don't know how
the show i just like
let me let me let me let me let me say
i've said a lot of these things too
because
we're supposed to mention you know ian
and lydia are here as well yes hello
but i always say one thing there's
there's two important things i think
about
uh well i'll say there's three things
why i think military service
is probably the best that if you had if
i had two people and one person
you know and they're both running one at
military service i'd probably vote for
them you know so there's three things
first and foremost
especially if you have combat experience
but regardless you have basic training
you've you've you've toughened up you've
exercised you've taken
yourself seriously the the second thing
is
not everybody who joins the military is
doing it for some noble cause
because you know i i briefly uh lived on
a military base my sister was living on
fort carson in colorado
and so i met a lot of people who were
like i needed a job you know what i mean
but there are a lot of people who are
like i wanted to do something
something bigger than myself i wanted to
help i want to be you know help my
country
help my people and they're not doing it
to try and get rich because you're not
going to get rich doing it but i'll tell
you what
one of the best things is too is you
probably have a disdain for you for
bureaucracy
after getting out absolutely and in fact
in fact uh i i personally believe one of
the the main responsibilities
of a leader in in garrison before you go
to war is to be sort of like a filter
like of the bureaucracy the bureaucracy
is gonna pour a lot of stuff on you and
your job as a leader is to filter out
what matters make sure that your troops
can focus
on the mission and training on whatever
weapon system that they have or whatever
duty position that they have
it's interesting like why i why i joined
the military
is you know i don't come from a long
line of you know military leaders or
military members in my family i was a
sophomore in college in elementary
education at clarion university which is
a
small university in western pennsylvania
elementary education major
right but didn't really know what i
wanted to do with my life i was like
most
sophomores in college and that i just
you know i wasn't sure that maybe being
in a classroom with kids
eight hours a day for the rest of my
life was really what i wanted to do even
though i knew i wanted to serve
in some way give back to the community
and i remember
having a conversation with my roommates
thinking like well my god like
our like our generation at the time we
didn't really like have a moment
right like you had like the cold war
before us and you had
your contingency operations in panama
and then you had desert storm but like
our generation was really a golden age
you know a post-clinton era of a
balanced budget where democrats and
republicans work together like we didn't
really want for anything growing up from
as a kid even though i was from a middle
class family and my parents lived
paycheck to paycheck i mean
i had a pretty good carefree life and
i had i remember having this discussion
with my roommates
and then we had this big party over the
weekend and i remember waking up on my
on this run down college couch one day
surrounded by iron city beer cans
i feel like we had come off the bender
of a lifetime and there were like
cigarette butts out all around us and
stuff and i remember sitting up and the
world was spinning i had this hangover
of a lifetime and i remember
staggering over to the television set
and
turning it on and watching it flicker to
life just in time to see an airplane
crash into the world trade centers
and you know i i feel like in that
moment
my life was just i i just remember
staggering a few steps back
and sitting on that rundown couch just
transfixed
to that television set of just images of
just raw horror of
innocent americans dying on live
television remember watching people
tumble from those towers and land on the
sidewalk
or people who were lucky enough to
survive that fateful day stagger out of
that wreckage covered firefighters who
ran
into the building and that was it yeah
tim that was what did it for me
is watching how the first responders
reacted the police officers firefighters
were just ordinary american citizens
with no training whatsoever run into the
flames instead of running away from them
yep
and i remember thinking as a college kid
how can i sit here and do nothing
when ordinary american citizens are
giving everything
for people that they didn't know and you
know anybody that lived through that day
knows that most people who ran into
those towers that day
to save people never came out again with
their life yep
and and that was it i mean two days
later i was down at the recruiter's
office told him i want to join the
infantry and not just that go to
airborne school and not just that go to
ranger school and
um and then i went home to talk to my
parents about the decision
it was kind of kind of crazy and i
remember getting in this
big argument with my with my father um
and he
as we were driving back to clarion it
was like a 45 minute drive back to
to the university and he was like trying
to convince me
look you got two years left of school
just stay in school go in as an officer
and at the time i mean i didn't know the
difference between yeah you know it's
good advice so isn't it
yeah yeah i mean i didn't know the
difference between a non-commissioned
officer enlisted
versus officer and i mean i was arguing
because i wanted to get in the fight
right now we had just been attacked and
i remember like
my my dad was just relentless and i
remember um
i remember looking at my dad and i i
remember saying to him you know
you know dad you know what the heck have
you ever done to be proud of in your
life i just want to serve my country and
he didn't say anything in return and i
was like oh i really know i crossed the
line here and the car just got quiet for
about 10 minutes
and my dad that's looked at me and he
goes well i have four things that i'm
proud of every day
you know you your younger sister and
your two younger brothers and i was like
oh
yeah i really screwed up you know
um and so i took his advice stayed in as
an officer
uh or stayed in college came out as an
officer and
uh graduated from college in 2004
duquesne university in the heart of
pittsburgh pennsylvania
and was immediate active duty and just
got thrown into the fray
you know two years later i was in
afghanistan college kid to combat
veteran in two years
wow and as a commissioned officer though
as a commissioned officer brand new
second lieutenant
i went to my officer basic course went
to airborne school went to ranger school
ranger school was absolute hell um i
failed the first time
through but begged the brigade commander
to let me stay who tried to kick me out
he's like
you're out here ranger and i'm like i
ain't going anywhere sir no seriously
ranger pack your stuff and get out of
here i'm like no seriously sir i'm not
going anywhere
so you let me stay in these barracks for
three weeks and wait for the next class
to start
ranger school is divided into three
phases like the georgia phase the
mountain phase and the swamp phase in
florida
all of them are horrible i went into
ranger school 225 pounds running six
minute and 30 second miles the best
shape of my life
i came out of ranger school 160 pounds
wow
because you're marching probably 20
miles a day you're not sleeping they've
got to give you three hours of sleep at
night but it doesn't have to be
concurrent
so it'd be five minutes here five
minutes there and
you just don't eat yeah you just don't
eat it's it's it's it's absolutely
horrible and it's supposed to be
the school was meant to train you on
small unit tactics
under extreme duress so can you lead
while you're starving and have n
and have no sleep by the end of that
school
feel for feel free to come over here
when the apocalypse starts we got
refer to you you tell me what to do tim
i i well first of all of course
i i'll do that in a second uh this place
is sweet but i
i was not i mean i relied on my ranger
buddies to get me through i mean we we
all
i mean they have this cool they have
this thing at the end of every phase at
the end of the georgia phase which is
sort of like where they the rap
ranger assessment phase which is like
like similar to navy seal like hell week
you know where they put you through that
and like they put you through all these
sorts of assessments like drown proofing
you know five mile run
pt test the malvesti pit which is like
just like
it was just miserable and at the end of
that you do a 20 mile they they call it
the
the march of unknown it's like sort of a
march of unknown distance you just march
to darby but the reality is they just
march you forever
yeah and you arrive i mean it's funny
because like it
i think that what that teaches you is
that you march until you're done yeah
like a lot of people would be like okay
we're going to be done at 10 miles oh no
we're not
oh it's just one more mile and we'll be
down at 15 miles they're not going to
march this past 15 miles
yeah then you get to 15 miles and you go
to 16 miles and so you'd be surprised
how your mind plays tricks on you and
people just quit when they don't know
when you're going to finish and i think
what that teaches you is you just
go until the mission is complete and so
i think at the end of
ranger assessment phase i think we
marched 20 miles into darby where you do
all the patrols but
anyway by the end of ranger school
people are so tired
and so starving that they hallucinate
you see people in the middle of the
night like trying to
like buy cans of pop from trees and
stuff and like it's crazy man
but i made it through that 160 pounds um
and went up to the fort drum the 10th
mountain division in watertown new york
and spent
six months six and a half years in the
military i think four or five up at fort
drum
and 485 days 16 months of heavy combat
along the afghan-pakistan border
wow where our mission in 2006 was
find osama bin laden that was it we
looked for him for
16 months we didn't find him but we
found
we found a lot of bad guys a lot of bad
guys in fact
thousands of enemy troops and we fought
against a global jihadist all-star team
of whether it was akane network
troops uh al qaeda taliban hekmatier
we were we fought against all of them
and took an 85
casualty rate uh as like i said and i
think we killed
350 enemy insurgents but we didn't hurt
one single civilian and we did a lot of
good things for the afghan people built
schools
wells humanitarian assistance uh we
really did care a lot about the afghan
people there but we
did which is an excellent uh i don't
wanna cut you off though no no of course
but it's a good segue into the covent
bill there's things they're spending
money on at a time of crisis
yeah yeah yeah so i mean you mentioned
building schools and stuff in
afghanistan yeah
yeah that's that's that is amazing i
have a lot of respect for that
at right now i wonder why it is would we
focus on things like that
well i mean this coveted bill i tried to
jump to this a little bit too early in
the intro of your show but
um i have a lot of issues with this
covid bill on a number of different
levels one of which is a process issue
right like the idea that
a 5 300 page bill
is given to congress with what three or
four hours to read
before they actually vote on the bill i
got a huge problem with that right
um it's it's i would say we should all
have more than a problem with it
that they are telling us screaming in
our faces on every tv channel in every
newspaper
the system is broken we know it's broken
and we don't care
because even aoc and josh hawley i
criticized them earlier and
and i'll define them in a second but
listen they both tweeted about how this
was awful they're doing this 5543 or
whatever pages
with only a couple hours to read it and
they voted for it yeah so if you're
going to speak out against it come on
vote no
like rand paul did like ted cruz did
like uh you know
i think it was like 65 or more
republicans only two democrats voted no
and it was tulsi gabbard and rishi tula
now in their defense at least they spoke
up against it
hundreds of other members of congress
voted for a ridiculous omnibus
2.3 trillion garbage bill that includes
things like this
this is from the foundation for economic
education 10 million dollars for gender
programs in pakistan
wonderful that's exactly what the
american people have been begging for
they've been
coming together and rising up these
conservative protesters in oregon i know
what they were really saying
kate brown we want gender diversity
programs in pakistan
10 million dollars i know it's not going
to change the change changing face of
the country it's
it's uh this is this is the this is my
next look so here's the deal
right the american people for the better
part of a year
have gone bankrupt have seen their small
businesses close
in western pennsylvania and my district
i've seen food lines every single week
thousands of people are struggling to
put food on the table for their families
the american people are hurting and
optically
this is what you do at a time when the
american people are hurting when they're
desperate for relief
not only do you give them 600 bucks and
by the way like to anybody that's
that's watching right now if you take
the just the the 900 billion dollar plus
coveted relief right
and you just do the quick math uh 330
million people that's 2700 bucks for
every man woman and child in america
right they could have given us 2 700
bucks
now instead of doing that the government
took
twenty seven hundred dollars from every
man woman and child in america
and gave you six hundred dollars back it
would be said merry christmas
that's on unacceptable in every way it
would be like if i robbed you
at gunpoint took your wallet took all
your cash out
and then said here's 20 bucks and you
went awesome thank you so much
right and so to your point of building
schools for afghan children is amazing
teaching little girls to read in
afghanistan is great because we want to
make sure that we shape that next
generation but
do it in a different bill timing and
optics are important like
you're looking at 700 million dollars
for sudan 1.4
billion to the asia reassurance
initiative act which again the asia
reassurance initiative act i don't have
a problem with really what it what it
basically is
it funds counter insurgency in asia
basically keeps an eye on china i got no
issues with that but
don't put it in a covid relief bill the
problem with these omnibus spending
bills right
is that congress doesn't read them they
don't have enough time to read them and
because
our representatives the people that we
send to washington to do our work for us
and look out for us
the people don't know what's in them
either and nobody does and
here's omnibus spending bills only get
bigger
they don't get smaller which is why our
debt in the last 10 years has gone from
11 trillion
to 27 trillion dollars now that now the
debt to
uh to gdp ratio is a scarier thing 128
percent right
yes so we're generating massive debt and
we're producing nothing
and that is how you kill economies this
is this that's how you kill economies
this is a national security issue
and this will become probably the
greatest leadership
challenge of of our time
and you know
i am gravely concerned with
with the amount of debt that we're
racking up in this country and bills
like this
don't help trying to explain it to
people is it's it's
it's such a genius move on the part of
the criminal
mass wearing bandits who just ripped us
off to to quote the babylon b
yeah yeah because what they've done is
they've found a way to extract the
the value of labor from the working
class in a way they don't notice
so i i have i've you know there's like
this one guy i know i was arguing with
and he's like why are they only giving
us six hundred dollars and i was like no
they're not giving you six hundred
dollars brother
they're taking 2700 and giving you 600
back yeah and you and
they don't understand like what do you
mean they're writing me a check i'm
getting money
listen they they've printed 35
of all u.s dollars in in circulation
have been
printed in the last 10 months so that's
all happening right now
and that dilutes your buying power it
basically is a blanket wage reduction
but it's smart a working-class person
get 10 bucks an hour
like or you know a person barely
depending on how many hours they were
could be in
poverty levels they get 10 bucks an hour
and they're saying i want 15 i want 15
bucks an hour
and then they do something like this
that that 10 bucks an hour
can now buy you seven dollars worth of
groceries from the year before
and they don't realize they think well
i'm still getting the same rate
i had i'll tell you this man i was
shopping on amazon
and i was buying a tablet and so i
clicked it and it went into my shopping
cart
and then something happened i forgot
about it a day or so later i opened up
amazon again and it said price changes
in your cart
the tablet went from 500 to 650
that's that's the kind of thing i'm
talking about people don't get it for a
working class person for somebody who's
making 10 50 bucks an hour
that could be another week they have to
work another week to get the tablet so
they could do the job
and if you if you can't get access to
tools like that i mean i'll tell you
if you get a good phone a good
smartphone you can make good youtube
videos you can start a career you can
start a podcast
if you can get the if you can get some
basic you know cheap cheap equipment
i started doing everything i was doing
with just a cell phone not very good one
either just like a
basic smartphone i saved up and i bought
it imagine if
before i was able to buy it this crisis
happened
and then i go into the store and i'm
like i finally saved up the 300 bucks
for the phone they go it's 450 now
i would have been like i guess no phone
for me then i wouldn't have started live
streaming then i wouldn't have started
building up this company and then it
wouldn't even happen for me you know
what i mean
so there there there is a certain uh
degree of
having to earn and save to invest in
yourself invest in a business
they're extracting the buying power from
the working class rich people are going
to be fine
rich people can buy stocks i mean i'm
telling you man if you and bought amazon
stock if you bought bitcoin
you're you're sitting back and you're
laughing at all this well
i mean what what concerns me is that
six hundred dollars is i feel like
insulting
you know and and what's more
is that nancy pelosi was was given a
better
deal nine what six months ago
but sat on it the democrats in congress
sat on it did nothing with it
because she wanted to score cheap
political points against the president
didn't want to give him an economic win
before november 3rd
so what what the democrats and look
but come on sean could you imagine if
donald trump would have won
i mean the nightmare of this cheeto
fascist winning the american people
gladly
uh for went or this this this uh
1200 stimulus package in october because
they knew it was for the greater good
right defeating donald trump
no no no no you know i mean
i'm telling you i i see this i see this
pain in in pennsylvania
every single day i mean i these people i
reach out to them i
they call me on my cell phone i'm you
know like i said i i've tried to lead on
this issue and be there for them through
this time of crisis and again not just
for republicans but for democrats too
but to be clear
the democrats and the house of
representatives sat
on covid relief because they didn't want
to give
president trump an economic victory
before november third
the reason why that was important tim is
they made the political calculation
that yes the american people are going
to have to suffer even people that are
democrats that will likely vote for us
they're going to have to suffer for the
next six months so that we can beat
donald trump i find that i was joking of
course
i know i know i know some people might
not realize but
uh think about that the democrats
nancy pelosi held the american people
hostage
and here's what i love i i love hearing
this from these just like urban leftist
types
i call the you know what i want to try
and differentiate between
the actual economic left
who do pay attention to politics and
maybe we have disagreements on policy
but there's political commentators they
they they know a decent amount of their
stuff maybe
we think they don't know as much or or
whatever but you have these like low
information resistance type democrats
that they're they're not particularly
politically active
and they're complaining they're saying
but nancy pelosi passed her bill
earlier this year and mcconnell wouldn't
approve of it
and it's like what was in that bill what
that that was
that bill was the same problem we're
seeing with this garbage omnibus
they put a bunch of trash in it knowing
the republicans could not allow it to
pass
of course do you know what the major
sticking point and what nancy pelosi's
bill was is she wanted bailouts for
for poorly run radical liberal cities so
but she wanted to get rid of voter
uh she wanted to to get rid of voter id
laws yeah that was all crammed in there
too
nonsensical what i told people in
pennsylvania and in my district
and in my opponent at the time was a big
proponent of taking
taxpayer dollars from the people of
pennsylvania and bailing out a city like
portland
that had already defunded their police
and let their city burn for
six months it's immoral to take
our tax dollars from hard-working people
in western pennsylvania who are already
struggling to bail out
poorly run liberal cities that's the
major point or how about
to fund gender diversity programs in
pakistan yeah
i mean yes i mean so yes optically we're
back to the to the coveted bill it it
was an
it's an absolute disaster um and
my fear is is is that problems like this
are only going to get worse and the
point that i was making before this is
that
it's looking like look i i don't know
what the future holds and you know that
uh i'm i'm a supporter of president
trump i've talked to the president on
multiple occasions i'm always going to
fight for the people of this country i i
believe
uh uh in president trump and
but it's amazing now that
some of the more you know career
politicians in washington
they see the writing on the wall they
see president trump
that maybe in january you know you've
got a guy like joe biden that
that likely be sworn in as president did
you see
with this bill how fast the swamp
on both sides of the aisle went back to
being
the swamp oh yeah right we didn't see
irresponsible spending bills like this
in the news
for four years under president trump
don't get me wrong this is one of the
areas where i disagree with the
president
a lot is is his spending he spends a lot
more than i'm comfortable with and so i
i disagree with him on a lot on deficit
spending and things like that but i
would also argue that
in the middle of a crisis and a pandemic
once a hundred year pandemic that this
the
times like this are precisely meant for
deficit spending
but but my my point is the swamp
has gone back to being the swamp in
record time so i i remember uh
talking to uh some family earlier this
year
and they were saying you always rag on
democrats all you do is democrats this
democrats that
and i'm like i i criticize republicans
admittedly
you do much less than i criticize
democrats and i'm gonna show
everybody listening exactly why i am
right
i have here from govtrack.ushr 133
consolidated appropriations act 2021
including coronavirus stimulus and
relief
we can see in the senate 46 democrats
vote yay
two independents which who caucuses the
democrats vote yay
44 republicans vote ye but what's this
six republicans
uh voted nay and two republicans
abstained
at least we have them and i'll give a
shout out to
rick scott rand paul marsha blackburn
ted cruz mike lee and ron johnson
now those politicians are not far from
perfect you can criticize them for a
bunch of different things
but at least they have the political
willpower to say i'm not signing this
thing
yeah it gets better gets better we jump
over to
the house vote hr 133 and once again
we have 128 republicans yay 230
democrats yay one independent yay
we have 50 republicans nay rejecting
this
17 republicans abstain grow spine guys
say no
and then only two democrats actually
voted against this
of all of congress we ended up with
56 republicans saying no and what was
that what was the uh let's let's pull
this back up and get the
abstaining we had two abstentions so 19
republicans abstained from the vote and
only two democrats
and it was tulsi gabbard who i am a big
fan of and have praised
and rashida taleb who have been very
critical of but my respect to her for
saying no to this
i don't know what her reasons were and
ever each one of these politicians might
have a different reason
but ultimately saying no to this garbage
was the right thing
well yeah i mean again because
coveted relief should be for coveted
relief
exactly there are lots of and it should
be bigger and it should be for the
american people uh
look i i i think that we should have
done direct payments to the american
people i like
2 400 bucks uh for for people i think
that was president trump's number in the
in the past something that is that can
actually help them pay their bills
uh what i really liked is the pay tech
protection program uh and
in fact before this bill was voted on uh
the democrats in the house of
representatives i think
voted against at least twice perhaps a
third time
uh extensions of the pay tech potential
protection program which would simply
have
extended the program through the end of
the year right real simple vote extend
the program through the end of the year
and streamline the forgiveness process
right the democrats in the house of
representatives voted against that three
times
and so i got massive problems with that
uh
lydia pulled up the story from news wkrg
five what's uh what's the date on this
this is from
december 22nd trump calls on congress to
amend covet 19 relief bill to increase
stimulus checks to 2000 per person
remove wasteful and unnecessary items
yes
but you see what rand paul's response to
all this was if
six hundred why not twelve hundred
twelve months right now ten thousand
yeah twenty thousand universal basic
income i mean you could fix this problem
tomorrow
if you just adopted a more surgical
pandemic response
and so i i will say that i think the
political motivations in blue states and
governors like
newsom pritzker in illinois uh cuomo and
new york
wolf in in my home state of pennsylvania
i believe that these second lockdowns
are not just because of the coronavirus
i believe that they're making a
political calculation and trying to put
pressure on mitch mcconnell
to bail out you know as i mentioned
poorly run liberal states and liberal
cities
you know by locking down the economy
more right
it puts more pressure on small
businesses more pressure on mr mcconnell
to bail
to give him what give those governors
what they want
i i've thought about you know we went
through the first lockdown so
let's let's let's uh we'll use a segue
into the
the big story that we want to talk about
i remember earlier this year
watching videos coming out of china
where it's like someone's on a bus and
they point the camera out the window and
then someone just falls over and it was
like watching sean of the dead i don't
know if you guys have seen that movie
where he's like riding and he sees the
person fall over and he's like looking
we saw a bunch of those videos it was
freaky and what was happening is that
people were having respiratory issues
from kovan and then just like
earlier in the year we had a very
serious problem so we all agreed okay
we're going to lock down for 15 days
because we can't stop this thing right i
didn't agree with that by the way
well i did because i the idea was
flatten the curve right how many how
many people forgot that already
it didn't work well it did work kova
just went haywire anyway
it went haywire okay it came back and so
what happened was we did flatten the
curve
and then we had this big flat period and
now it's spiking again proving it's not
going to stop
and we can't just stay locked down
forever
so the the appropriate response now i
believe is protect the vulnerable
social distancing masks and reopening
everything well so so i think let go
back to the just go back to the very
beginning
in january um i saw
what i saw coming out of china uh was
very concerning to me
and the truth is i didn't know nor did
anybody else to include our intelligence
community
what we were dealing with in covet and i
think back then we didn't even have a
name for it
um and so tom cotton and i think i i
think tom cotton and i were the first
people in the country to say
we need to ban all travel from china
yeah until we can figure this out and
they got mad at soundcloud oh
they got mad at tom cotton they got mad
at me over xenophobic and then i think
the president a couple days later banned
travel from china
uh this was all while impeachment uh
articles of impeachment by the way were
being delivered from
the house to the senate uh and then the
president
in an address in fact i was in
washington dc at the time
uh and the president banned all travel
from europe and
i remember watching that thinking oh my
god this is serious he's doing a
presidential address banning all travel
from europe is a big deal
definitely um and this was at the time
where nancy pelosi was passing out
impeachment pens and telling people to
go out in chinatown and mayor de blasio
saying go see a movie
um come on down to chinatown joe biden
again
calling calling donald trump xenophobic
a hysterical
xenophobic but i know i know that the
media loves to push this fake fact check
where they're like biden never called
trump xenophobic
yeah to specify he in response to
trump's call for banning travel
uh to china joe biden said we don't need
donald trump xenophobia
so it was very clear he was calling
trump a xenophobe in response to this
but the media goes but he didn't call
him that he said he was ex
okay shut up media yeah so so my point
is is that i
i was okay with the lockdowns early on
precisely because we didn't know enough
about the virus i mean for god's sake it
could have had a fifty percent fatality
right yeah
and in those instances just from a
strategic pandemic military response
standpoint
when you don't know a whole lot about
the pathogen you wanna make sure that
you protect people and keep them
isolated as long as possible until you
learn
about what this thing can do my point is
after 15 days to slow the spread then 30
days to slow the spread then two months
to slow their spread then six months
but the point is we know a lot more
about covet 19 today than we did in
january
we know who would expect yeah we we've
got therapeutics regeneron i mean
uh we've we've got uh hydroxychloroquine
by the way which is now
the ama came back now now now it's cool
because the predator because yeah
the election's over hydroxycork and
actually the american medical
association reversed their previous
advice on
exactly hydroclerquin amazing exactly
and so not only that now we've got two
effective uh vaccines and by the way you
know people that criticize the
president's pandemic response again does
president trump always say the right
thing no
uh but his this public-private
partnership
uh uh project airbridge was an
unprecedented success
personal protective equipment ppe uh at
levels that we never thought possible by
simply
partnering with private institutions
that make them available and he got
criticized no no
not being enough personal protective
equipment democrats were actually
praising him
we had cuomo and newsome actually going
oh it's a time right right right at the
time yes they were crazy
and fauci said we're doing a great job i
don't think anybody could have done
anything better
we developed so many ventilators in this
country in such a short amount of time
that we didn't even come close to using
what we created and what we made we sent
them all around the world
do you remember the hospital ships up in
new york city and outside l.a do you
know how many people went on the uss
conference
like one patient right i don't even
think it was a coveted patient right the
javits center
had like 30 capacity yeah and operation
warp speed was an
unprecedented success all of this stuff
happened
under president trump's leadership the
development of personal protective
equipment which by the way
uh our national stockpile of personal
protective equipment was completely
depleted
under obama and joe biden under the h1n1
think about this okay
donald trump oh i i remember getting a
twitter argument with some
some leftist and i said donald trump did
a good job on covid
and their only response was oh my god
are you serious and i was like
so we had a lefty on the show and the
first thing he brought up was i
understand
like when he was addressing it there's
no metric by which to judge
a good job or a bad job because
it's one leader it's one president doing
this one thing you can try and compare
it to historic historical moments or
whatever and
you can't do it right so i'm like you're
correct i i agree with that
and he goes and that being said here's
why trump did a bad job and i said well
i think trump did a good job
it's really about whether you like trump
that's what it boils down to is it's
trump's comportment
um people you know and i'll tell you
because we experienced this on the
campaign trail
um i don't know what it is i mean i
think when you talk about the
president's achievements whether it's
project airbridge or operation warp
speed or
or uh some of these unprecedented
public-private partnerships or
ventilator
uh uh production like all of these
things i mean were happened
in record time i mean the fact that we
have two
vaccines available to people in under a
year
is is is close to a miracle it happened
under president trump's leadership
but but people don't people didn't like
him at the podium during press
conference shortly yeah i know they
don't
like they didn't like how he interacted
with the media and so that was
enough for people to say well i just
i just i just i just don't like i don't
i don't think he's doing a good job
so trump is saying right now he will not
sign the coveted relief bill unless
americans get two thousand dollar
stimulus checks
but not now i wanna i wanna uh address
one very important thing though
here's here's the bit that i've been
doing in the past couple of days
democrats will come into the house or
the senate
and say we're proposing a bill to burn
down the house and they'll
light the match and then republicans go
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa only burn down the kitchen instead
of arguing for reopening the economy
and getting people back to work and
protecting the vulnerable donald trump
is just saying oh yeah democrats well
i'll one-up your leftist policy idea
and go even further left than you well
this is what
this is what the president represents
in the republican party today a massive
paradigm shift right
i would argue and contend that over the
last 30 years of my life
republicans have been conditioned to fly
the white flag of surrender at any
sign of adversity and i think that's
because
you know the democrats control every
single cultural institution in this
country they control the media
they control hollywood they control our
education system
and the republicans you know are afraid
of media criticism should they take a
stand well i've nev
the president i have never seen anyone
in my life now by the way
you know the president again ran as a
republican and i think he's a proud
republican
but he resists group think on both sides
of the aisle like no one i have
ever seen before well well you know why
and republicans and democrats in
washington
trump's don't i don't want to say they
don't like him but
he he can make enemies on both sides of
the aisle and he does it as a matter of
routine and i have to say
i i respect that trump's ego is just too
big for for better or for worse
he's a billionaire businessman who knows
better than these people
so when they come to him and say here's
what he goes i don't want to listen to
you
i know it needs to be done he believes
in himself he's he's
uh to a fault he's got he's arrogant
he's egotistical
but that can be good in his in in you
know so that's the negative aspect but
also he's just very very confident
and he's sure of himself so you've got
things to criticize him for but in the
same sense
it works out really really well for the
american people right now i actually
agree
with the the stimulus stimulus checks
not for what they're doing like
if they actually did a 900 billion
dollar stimulus package and everyone got
2700
i would wince like cringe a little bit
okay fine
if that money goes directly to the
american people it's their own buying
power being borrowed by themselves
i understand that giving it to you know
art institutions
and you know prominent universities for
like academic nonsense
and then tying it into the omnibus stuff
that's when things get out of hand
what it muddies the waters for sure i
would say about about president trump uh
you know part of
part of being a leader and one of the
things that i learned very early on as a
young leader in afghanistan is that as a
leader if you're not
upsetting people every now and again
you're not doing your job
and part of part of you know part of the
problem
in washington is we elect too many
lawyers too many politicians and not
enough leaders and i think
i disagree with tulsi gabbard on a lot
of things on a lot of issues of
substance
but i respect her you know she came she
came out today
and this is another issue that i have
you know members of congress getting the
vaccine before people in high risk
categories really
upsets me because there's a philosophy
in the military of
leaders eat last like when you're in the
field with your troops as a commander
as a leader i don't touch food until
every single member of my platoon is
eaten
and so you know tulsi gabbard came out
today and said hey
you know i disagree with elites in our
society or even people that are that are
that are you know what do they call
high-risk folks that are work that are
working
getting the vaccine prior to the elderly
well i mean
i i respect that i respect that and so
you know that's not that decision from
her is probably not going to earn her
any points within her political party
but again
part of being a leader is standing up
and doing what you believe in your heart
is right regardless of whether or not
you're going to get flack
she's proposing some bills you know with
all due respect on her way out
she's burning it down yeah i love it i
mean it's it's fairly
moderate what she's proposing but but i
i wanted to to
segway this into the bigger story we had
about the protesters
the conservative protesters because what
i what
what my concern is with extended
lockdowns
with or without with with or without a
stimulus check so trump comes out and
says we'll do two thousand dollars
and it's gonna make a whole lot of
people happy but it's also
going to be a it's essentially paying to
keep the lockdowns going
saying okay we can lock down because
we'll just keep printing money
until what it all becomes worthless so
now we're seeing conservative protesters
coming up and doing something you know
we mentioned this earlier in the show
that's uh as far as i can tell rather
unprecedented at least
at least in this culture war that we've
seen with the past several years first
of all
when i started covering actually let me
make sure i give you guys the context
before i get into this
the independent reports protesters
attack police with pepper sprays they
try to storm oregon capital stories from
a couple days ago
two people arrested on charges of
trespassing and assaulting an officer
it was bear sprayed and these were
conservatives using bear spray against
police while entering the building
they say about 300 members of the proud
boys patriot prayer and other groups
arrived at the reopen oregon rally
calling on governor kate brown to lift
pandemic restrictions as lawmakers met
in a special session to discuss stimulus
and vaccination distribution measures
i've been covering this stuff since
2011. i've been
on the ground at protest since i was a
teenager going down in chicago to these
you know anti-iraq war stuff
anti-afghan work protests and just
really complaining all the time
and when i started covering uh occupy
wall street
i never saw a conservative protest you'd
see like tea party stuff
and you know that that was i went to dc
once and i saw a bunch of lawn chairs
and it was a bunch of conservatives and
republicans waving little american flags
and i was like that's a protest yeah
well it was effective for him for sure
they they they played it smart they
played it better and meanwhile occupy
was very physical you know non-violent
civil disobedience mixed with what they
call the diversity of tactics which
really sullied and soured the whole
thing
but over the next several years we
started seeing you know proud boys come
out i remember going to berkeley
and seeing proud boys and it was like i
was like oh proud boys are out here like
they're just like you know drinking with
gavin and doing their videos and now
they're on the ground
now they're actually fighting with
antifa and
i remember i was in front of trump tower
and there was a trump supporter who's
just
regular guy regular clothes and there
were protesters and i was talking to him
and he said he was a trump supporter
and i said why aren't you protesting why
aren't you coming out and supporting
your president
and this is years ago and he was like oh
no no i i can't do anything like that
so i remember the first time i saw i
think it was in boston when i saw a
march of trump supporters chanting who
streets our streets
and i laughed and i'm like that's what
the left says now you've got
conservatives
organizing marching in protests i'll
tell you what i haven't seen
i have seen antifa throw bricks at cops
throw molotovs at cops
i've not seen them pepper spray cops
certainly i think the molotovs are way
worse
but it is it is fascinating to me and
i'm not saying that
in a good way i'm like this is crazy to
see conservatives
bear spraying cops because you gotta
really push the line
to make a conservative come after a cop
i mean these are these are people at
this protest
there are a couple of people waving thin
blue live thin blue line flags
clearly in support of police now someone
there
sprays the cops down with with bear mace
because these cops were barring them
from a hearing they were legally allowed
to enter
so windows got smashed cops shoved
people back couple people got arrested
i'll tell you we do hear in the media a
lot fears about what the right will do
if they finally feel compressed and
they're going to push back and i'm like
it's a good point
the problem is they bring it up when no
one no conservative is doing anything
like antifa comes out burns down a whole
city and they're like but they're the
good guys they're
fighting you know fascism and
conservatives are walking around with
little american flags
now you have the the very serious
question of
if conservatives have finally said the
these these officers
who are violating the constitution and
keeping us locked down and barring us
from a public hearing
if they're no longer on our side why
would it be on their side
but also it's also it's it's it's that
it's conservatives over the last year
have have have suffered just america has
suffered
uh but also conservatives are banned
conservatives
are canceled for the last four years
they they made
conservatives out to be conspiracy
theorists they called us names
deplorables
chumps you name it i mean every every
conservatives are constantly i mean look
what
look at what antifa did
to elderly conservatives who
walked out of the republican national
convention and back to their hotels on
the last night in washington dc
this country has been under attack
under attack by the radical left for the
better part of a year
and conservatives have sat back and done
nothing but take it on the chin
every single month and so i i'm
i'm not saying gosh i would like i don't
like violence
violence is unacceptable on either side
uh but
we are in the middle of i think the
greatest one of the greatest
constitutional one of the greatest
constitutional crisis
crises that we that we've ever
experienced in this country
conservatives already feel like they
don't have a voice this is
what's happening when when free speech
and the first amendment is essentially
cancelled or free speech is suppressed
bad things happen and and and part of
the
i think that's part of what we're seeing
here today you know those conservatives
in oregon
you know got in the fight with the cops
out there they were they were
they were unconstitutionally denied
their right to a public hearing
they're not violent they're they're not
they certainly got some of them got
violent
but it's very different from if a bunch
of like antifa people show up wearing
all black
they they typically act a fool and they
start threats and you say
take off your mask and hoodie in glasses
you can come in the building i'm fine
with that
if and if someone wants to protest and
come out and yell rabble rabble and they
want to wear sunglasses a mask and a
hoodie
that's fine too you want to commit a
violent act that's not okay
but what's what's crazy now is antifa
fights cops
they fight cops we got that video as i
like seattle i think they threw a
molotov at cops that was that's crazy
i mean they're not just talking about
trying to kill the guy they're trying to
they're talking
when you throw a molotov at somebody
you're not just trying to commit murder
you want to make sure they suffer the
whole way through and if they survive
they
they have permanent injuries for the
rest of their lives that's
psych that's psychotic now conservatives
who typically and spent the whole year
defending the police
they're mad at him the police need the
support
of anybody they can get especially when
against the wishes of many of the
members of the public they're defunding
police
minnesota this is hilarious city council
votes to abolish their police department
all of a sudden crime rates start
skyrocketing locals are calling their
city council members saying what's
happening why aren't the police
responding to calls anymore
they come into an emergency meeting okay
we got to go backwards we want to do
over
as a mistake it was a mistake they're
doing it even though people are saying
not to
and conservatives the whole time have
been saying back the blue
defend the police not defund the police
but what happens when the police don't
get that support because the police are
the ones now
so who are shutting down businesses
during the riots in june
antifa were destroying small businesses
and burning down buildings
well now the videos i see in big cities
and big cities
they're democrat cities mind you it's
the police doing it it's the nypd who
stood in front of that bar in staten
island
and and and basically looked the guy in
the face and said you have no
constitutional rights because we say so
and they and will arrest you if you try
and let people into your building
you have the first amendment says
peaceably assemble it doesn't say why
if i want to peaceably assemble to you
know play marbles or whatever i'm
allowed to do it
if someone says i'm going to open up my
business i have a right you know i have
a right to open to the public
his constitutional rights publicly
assembled the police barred the building
who are those cops to fight the
constitution that way well i mean that
this is part of this is part of the
reason why i say that you know
the police should should not follow
unconstitutional orders
they they and and certainly in the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
we've not experienced i mean i've not
seen uh i've not
i've not seen or had experiences like
that in fact most of the cops that i've
come into contact with
uh they loathe the orders in fact we've
had some sheriffs come out and say
simply we're not gonna we're not gonna
enforce them good they're
the government does not have a right to
deny your ability to make a living
the government does not have a right to
tell you what you have to wear in your
own house
the government doesn't have a right to
tell you how many people you can have
in your own house so if you're a police
officer and you get a call
and you know maybe a neighbor tells on
you tells on you get a call and you show
up to someone's house and they got a
couple people in their house
you shouldn't you shouldn't be enforcing
unconstitutional orders
and and they're and exactly there are
orders they're not laws
there's no statutory backing to this it
was some governor or mayo
mayor just saying do it and there are
cops who are doing
it and also can we also just have a
conversation about that like
in pennsylvania we're locked down again
governor wolf locked us down he shut
down restaurants and indoor dining
you know first of all there's absolutely
no science behind this right
and you're shutting down restaurants you
know what you know what happens when you
shut down restaurants if anything we
should be opening up
more restaurants to allow people to
spread out more but when people can't go
out to a restaurant you know what they
do they entertain at home
they go to their friend's house they go
to their friends houses so if you're
looking for
if you're looking to stop the spread of
covid19
and you actually look at some of the
contract tracing research that says 76
percent of the spread happens in
people's own home
what you're doing by closing restaurants
is is shunting people back into their
own homes
which according to your own research
allows for the spread of covet 19.
didn't the supreme court already rule
that like the lock the first lockdown in
pennsylvania was
the federal court the federal court and
then another judge took it up and struck
it down we've got we've got
so many so many experiences with the
court systems but
let me let me show you this from vox.com
december 10th southern california
sheriffs are refusing to enforce
stay-at-home orders it's these big blue
cities
so there's another reason why i'll
always say the acab people are wrong
somebody commented i i so i i made a
music video in november
and it's uh it's called will the people
you can check it out but it's about the
cycle of authoritative and violence
and someone commented it was really
funny they said you made an entire video
showing how the bad guys are the police
and like the people are rising up
against them to remove the dictators and
and they're always backed by the cops
and i'm like
when you when you have blue areas when
you have
democrats and the police there don't
care about the constitution
yes you have a problem when you have
these places in southern california
where the sheriffs uphold the
constitution
when you have places in smaller towns
and it's and local cops
who uphold the constitution the cops are
the good guys
the ones protecting you from the despots
from the authoritarians
the greatest hedge against
authoritarianism is our constitution
our constitution protects all americans
is a shield for all americans
against authoritarian government this is
why
uh my understanding is most cops swear
notes uphold the constitution
absolutely and they take it seriously
and when they do
they are literally the good guys when
they don't they're literally bad guys
yeah police is a verb like if i give you
a gun i'm like go walk around and make
sure no one's out there
you be you're policing the area whether
or not you are adhering to the
conversation has nothing to do with it
some of those guys did take oh this and
if they're violating them that's a
problem but anyone
can police well it really does come down
to cops as the most
important group of people and i'm not
saying important as a good or bad thing
the most consequential group of people
in this country right now
are cops who are upholding their
constitution or breaking it in new york
we're seeing them break it
and that means people's lives are being
destroyed in areas like southern
california we're seeing them behold it
and they're the heroes
stopping the the fascists well i'll i
have no problem calling them
use their own word against them these
these democrats that feel they have a
right to give our taxpayer dollars
to massive corporations to shut
everything down by edict
that's their fascists well and and then
when you see
some of the reporters talking to
governor wolf it it really is
it would be hysterical if it weren't
tragic for these restaurants who are
closing in record numbers
in the state of pennsylvania reporters
asking him well
why are you closing restaurants what
what research are you using do you know
he's saying he's like uh well
uh i i i can't think of a more dangerous
thing than people sitting with me but
but there's no research to support
that that the spread of covet 19 is
happening in restaurants especially when
restaurants have invested tens of
thousands of dollars
in in taking 50 capacity people are
spread out they've got plexiglass or
they're outdoors
all your all you're effectively doing is
taking someone's ability to make a
living
three weeks before before christmas it's
not just the owners of the restaurants
it's the bus boys it's the cooks it's
the servers
all of these people are gonna have not
only trouble putting food on the table
for their family
but they're having they're gonna have
issues
christmas for their children for god's
sake it's really really frustrating to
me so i mean i've stood up in
pennsylvania and i feel like i'm the
only one in pennsylvania saying
restaurants stay open cops disobey
unconstitutional orders and it's working
except for now we've got government
government and health uh
the health department showing up to
restaurants and inside of one one
restaurant in western pennsylvania
giovanni's it's an italian restaurant
health department came in there
and said well you're not supposed to be
open for for in-person dining
and he said well i can't make a living
if i don't so they came back the next
day they pulled his health permit and
they said oh we'll make you a deal we'll
let you do takeout and he said i
i lose money when i do take out i'm
staying open he said well guess what we
got to shut you down now
how are they going to do it well he
didn't listen so are they going to send
cops in
i don't i look if if they do i don't i
don't think i
i i don't know i hope that i hope that
the cops
don't i hope that they don't comply i
don't think that they will but but the
point is
people are starting to push back and and
what i said earlier in the program
is a government derives power from the
consent of the people the moment we no
longer consent the government has no
power to impose
any unconstitutional lockdowns and again
i'll say this again because there'll be
some radical left group that's going to
take this out of context and say that i
don't care about covet i do care about
covet a lot i think we need to adopt a
more
surgical pandemic response i think that
we can protect small businesses and
protect people's ability to make a
living while simultaneously protecting
public health i think we can do both
not only that i think at this point
i don't i don't care what the response
being offered up is as long as it's not
locked down you know why
we did the lockdown didn't work the
science behind them
is dubious at this point anybody that's
advocating for lockdowns at this point
in the game
is not looking at the data and not
looking at it but but i'll clarify the
first point of the lockdowns was not to
stop
everyone from getting coveted it was to
make it so the hospitals could handle
the load by spreading it out
that was the goal of the lockdown we did
now it's back
we we slowed the spread it came back
with a vengeance we can't just do it
again because clearly it's just going to
keep coming back
we have to do something else so my
question is though with these protesters
at what point do conservatives
i don't know escalate as it were my
there's a town called mossy brook in
washington where the mayor just said
we're exempt from the lockdown just by
his own decree
and so the city is just normal patriot
prayer you know right-wing groups showed
up and they partied
i i think you know people what the
government is doing
is risking the loss of their legitimacy
when you have police in new york and
other big cities
violating the constitution well then
people feel like
the government is illegitimate when you
have police officers
who defy the the elected government like
in southern california to defend the
constitution
then people are gonna start feeling like
their elected government is illegitimate
if the constitution is not being
protected or the or the the governors
are trying to
rip it apart then people are going to
lose confidence at what point do we
start seeing
small towns and right-wing groups just
set up their own checkpoints or whatever
and say
you have no power here to like the cops
when they go hungry when they start
going hungry
god i hope that never happens i think we
can avoid all of that by simply
disobeying the orders period
the the most effective way because i
this is the most by the way by the way
tim
like when i say disobey the orders i'm
simply saying restaurants stay open
small businesses stay open
if you want to leave your house and you
want to go shopping then go shopping
follow cdc guidelines wear a mask in the
store
if you're if you're somebody that's
afraid of covid
right or if you're somebody that has a a
pre-existing condition
or if you're in a high-risk category you
know stay home order groceries online
look to your neighbor for help maybe
they'll go grocery shopping for you but
there are ways
the human beings will find i mean we'll
find a way
to be safe and be responsible during all
this but
the point that i'm making is i don't
think a top-down
draconian government lockdown is the
answer because
you know there's that all afraid from
ronald reagan like uh i'm from the
government and i'm here to help that
scares me i don't want the government's
help i think the vast majority of
americans don't want the government
they're loaning out
money so basically we're taking a loan
from the federal reserve that we have to
pay back at interest just to pay
ourselves
for children and your children and so
the debt gdp debt to gdp ratios 126 you
said
120 once it gets to 130 you mentioned a
number 32 is
you're gonna have like real real
problems and what historically do very
poor countries with huge militaries do
they don't disband yes
i don't know who we would invade right
now though iran
how about iraq and afghanistan and syria
and libya and
all that how about yeah how about this
is what i'm talking about
desperation iran is the is the target
well
i i i i i don't know i mean i feel like
we racked up a lot of debt
in afghanistan and and in iraq iraq more
so than
afghanistan but who wrecked the debt up
and who benefited from it
because there are individuals probably
in government who either just didn't
care and voted yes
because they're not going to see this or
there are people who had stock in
certain companies and were like i'll
vote for war fine
whatever my my fear is is is not about
you know the the united states
potentially invading you know another
country although i mean i'm always
worried about sending our troops into
harm's way for a number of different
reasons and the potential foreign policy
implications that come along with that
i i am very very worried uh about the
ccp the chinese communist party
definitely i'm very very taiwan if they
go in on taiwan i mean what's america
going to do well
joe biden will do nothing i said i said
you know
if you end up seeing a biden presidency
you mark my words i think
and this is this is just what i know of
china and how they operate and i've been
watching them for the last 10 years of
my life
i think you'll see china go quiet and
then i think you'll see them invade
taiwan
and then you're going to that'll be one
of them soon yes and so
but look the chinese communist party
has infiltrated every level of our
government
and that is not sean parnell on tim
poole in a conspiracy theory
this is what a chinese professor said at
a chinese
presentation said that we've got people
at every level of the chinese communist
party he even brought up paying hunter
biden in the biden family
a couple weeks later you have eric
swalwell come out with with fang fang
being compromised by a chinese spy
you had a chinese spy driving around
dianne feinstein for 20 years now get
this and
no one no one's talked about this i'm
going to talk about it on your show for
the
for the first time a high-level chinese
diplomat
met with the allegheny county executive
rich fitzgerald in august of 2019
why is a high-level chinese official
communist party official meeting with a
county executive you know how i found
that information
on the on the chinese communist party
new york city consulate website
where they said that in this meeting oh
rich fitzgerald the allegheny county
executive welcomed us with open arms
we said that wuhan in pittsburgh are
sister cities
and we stand in august of 2019 three
months before a pandemic wuhan in
pittsburgh or sister cities
what gives an allegheny county executive
the authority to make a declaration like
that number one
number two how is it okay for a county
executive and local democratic officials
to meet with a senior a high-level
chinese diplomat
to sub to subvert and by the way this is
on the ccp's
website to subvert the president's
trade policy in china and foreign policy
in china and stand steadfast in our
friendship
did you see this uh this story that came
out uh just about a week ago
data leak exposes details of two million
chinese communist party members i saw
that
the u.s and the uk have been infiltrated
by members of the communist chinese
party some of these biggest companies
some of them working for some of these
major pharmaceutical companies so i have
to wonder when i see something like that
when i see uh fung fung you know eric
swalwell
allegedly was having relations with this
woman and she helped fundraise for his
campaign
my question is why hasn't he resigned
already why is he on the intel committee
why isn't he under investigation having
every single communication ripped apart
and gone through the fine-tooth comb
and then when i see stories about this
guy fitzgerald you're mentioning now in
allegheny county
oh it's it's you notice this because
this is your county
right yeah it's part of my district you
you you're this is your
you know where you're this is my first
foray into politics you know i'm a war
fighter so i'm just starting to
notice this stuff but think about this
think about how many other counties
how many others and then i wonder you
say what gives him the authority why
does he do it
man i wonder if all it takes is some
hacker
a chinese communist party member who you
know hacks into his account
finds his uh naughty folder and then
blackmails them with it
they have a meeting and they say oh take
a look at this image well look that's
that's part of their playbook
but china knows our china knows the game
the chinese communist party
does not want for resources part of what
they do part of right out of the chinese
communist party playbook
is putting pressure on local state and
federal officials that they think
that they can get in with and it just so
happens i mean
look this is a republican and democrat
problem now i don't think that
i mean you've got dianne feinstein and
eric swalwell and then
you've got i i i i i technically agree
but i actually kind of disagree with
you saying it's a republican democrat
problem it's bad for all of us
it's bad for all of us as well i'm not
sure the democrats care
well i mean look if the democrats cared
eric swalwell would not be on the
intelligence committee
um if if the democrats joe biden would
not be president-elect or
will be on january 6th or about to be
i mean look this is a this is a problem
this is this is a
problem that that that deserves the
attention
of every power broker in this country in
the private sector
and every head of every government
agency needs to be focused on this now
too many too many people
are in on the take man look look look it
is not hyperbolic to say
that uh joe biden is likely compromised
by communist chinese interests
he flew his son on government property
air force on air force two
to china for a 1.5 billion dollar equity
deal now i thought didn't happen i
thought the equity fell through but we
had china uncensored on the show and
they said
no actually it did go through just not
the way people think the negotiations
were good it worked
they got a five million dollar interest
rate interest-free forgivable loan
joe biden flew his son to china for a
private
deal joe biden's involved of course he's
the big guy
he's the big one even even outside of
accusations right from these emails so
we have leaked emails
we well they're not leaked emails we
have the laptop was the emails were
published
we have confirmation from tony bob
yalinski who worked on some of these
deals
get rid of all that stuff just say just
say you know what okay to the you're
arguing with your democrat buddies say
forget it all
it is not in dispute that joe biden took
air force ii
to fly his son to china for private
equity deals
joe biden used government resources to
enrich his family
that is a fact not in dispute by anybody
and now this guy's on track to become
president look it's concerning
and i would say about you know allegheny
county executives local
local county executives it's not
uncommon for them to meet with diplomats
and welcome them to their cities but i
would say
why are you meeting with our number one
geopolitical foe
probably the greatest human rights
abuser on the planet they put people in
concentration camps their number one
goal is to become the lone superpower
overtaking the united states of america
does this not deserve questions from
maybe for somebody in the middle east i
used to always be like why were they so
nice to the nazis in 1930 why was hitler
man of the year why did
germany yeah why did they host the
olympics why was germany such the love
child of the world
in the early days when maybe their human
rights abuses weren't public knowledge
yet peace
i think it was yeah who said that
neville chandler
devil chamberlain said that so after his
abilities who brought that up on the
show right
yeah the saying peace in our time was
when neville chamberlain talked to
hitler
and they were like he comes back and
goes don't worry he says he won't attack
us yeah they gave him
and they did a piece of czechoslovakia
or something i don't know neville
chamberlain gave him a big piece of land
it was like he's not going to do any
he's not going to invade any more guys
the su dayton land i don't remember yeah
the idea the idea
that china is our friend that is being
you're hearing this
in the news from many in the democrat
party is
one of the greatest fallacies of our
time they are not our friend
they they do not want to be they want to
overtake our country they do not want to
cooperate with us
like look look it's very very very
concerning and
i'm telling you every leader in our
country needs to focus on this right now
but clearly people like swalwell either
don't care or
like it yeah i don't think he
intentionally took a spy under his wing
he'd resign if he cared
well now yeah i know and so if there was
enough of a public outcry he would
resign i don't know if it's that they
don't
care is that they're just ignorant to
the goals the foreign policy goals
of china or maybe they don't understand
well let me let me tell you something
when i worked for some for abc news
univision's joint venture fusion i
worked in the abc news building
i worked in the univision building i
worked for vice
what people think they think that
individuals get bribed to do things
they think that like i would go to you
and say hey i want you to you know steal
ian's glasses here's 10 bucks
well that's that's not how bribes work
that's not how the media works that's
not how political manipulation works
here's how it works
if you run a company that and you want
to be a woke progressive or conservative
company
you don't hire a journalist and then say
i'll give you extra money to lie and
make fake news
you seek out those who lie and make fake
news and say want a job
and they say yes i do here's your salary
do whatever you want because i already
know what you do
eric swalwell got help with his
political career from fong fung
the chinese communist party finds
feckless ignorant
morons and then says make them win how
can we make them win
why do we have feckless ignorant morons
in our in our government
because we are government of by and for
the people that's a popularity vote
because anybody can run so what they
what they
what they'll do now is they'll exploit
that system in any legal possible way
they can or even illegal
like we have a thousand talents program
these professors are getting huge stacks
of cash
from china and they're getting arrested
for because they're legal or they're
lying to the government about the money
they're getting
china's willing to break the rules and
they're willing to do whatever it takes
to exploit our system
and this the spy work who is helping
eric swalwell get elected is well that's
that's basically the point
swalwell probably wouldn't even be in
office
i don't know maybe not maybe he would
have that's fine but either way he
should have resigned the moment the
story broke
the moment he had us hit a briefing and
the fbi came in said you were propped up
by chinese spies
even if it were me i'd walk out and be
like i'm out i resign
straight up or at least take him off the
intelligence committee so that he
doesn't have access to our country's
most sensitive secrets
yeah that too yeah i mean but i don't i
don't think the democrats care
look at remember steve king remember
what happened to him when he tweeted
about white nationalism yes
he got booted off every every committee
then he lost the pre-order
because the republican party said we
don't want to associate with you and
what you're saying
so we want someone else that was the
republican party because the republicans
for all of their faults are still
substantially better than democrats in
many ways
i think both parties are full of crony
establishment garbage but you still have
a decent amount of people in the
republican party who are totally
disagree with you
i want to do something about it i mean
obviously i'm a republican but yes i
totally agree with you
i totally agree with you but again it's
just look at omar comes out and says all
that stuff about you know jews in israel
that was like the way the way i
described it was illinois omar was crop
dusting anti-semitism you know what crop
dusting is
the plane comes down and gets real close
to the ground but doesn't touch it
the things ill and omar said weren't
overtly anti-semitic but people were
like
you're reading into it but hold on you
said three things it's like if you said
one thing we'd be like that's weird
second time we go it's kind of weird
third time's like okay that's on purpose
right
but all that happened was nancy pelosi
said we want to condemn all bigotry
and no no penalties no censure no
punishment just we condemn bigotry have
a nice day everybody
steam king steve king tweets once and
they kick him out of the party he's gone
he loses
yeah bye-bye i know and so democrats
don't do it
and eric swawwell still sits on the
intelligence committee
even though he was compromised for years
by a chinese spy you know it's funny uh
there was a meme where they were like
chinese the chinese communist party is
sending beautiful young women
to basically like get in bed literally
with
up-and-coming stars politicians
personalities
and so now it's like if you are what did
someone say they say
if you're a two and she's a ten you
probably should you gotta ask some
questions
she's probably a spy this is probably
something's not right
um can we get swat while out of the out
of the committee impeach him
the only way he gets removed from the
committee is nancy pelosi removes him
from this
from the committee you know what man
have you seen what's going on with the
the
the force the vote thing on the
progressive left i i have seen this
although i i don't know enough about it
to discuss it in any depth i have seen
it i
read a little bit about it just today
this is why i think uh i'll tell you
another reason why i don't like the
democrats after everything we've just
explained about you know
kicking people out of the party and
booting them off you know their their uh
committees you have ocasio-cortez
and she and the progressive democrats
in the democratic party because the
republicans gained so many seats
they now have the leverage to force a
vote on basically anything they want
i think they're within five votes of the
majority right like it's like the house
is very very
i think i think the democrats have a six
or seven seat majority right now which
means if the progressives went to nancy
pelosi and said
unless you give us a floor vote on these
issues
we will not vote for you for speaker in
which case the republicans
could gain control to a certain degree
they're still the minority party oh for
sure
so you have jimmy dore who is he's
progressive but he's populist and i
think he's a good dude
and he said you were elected to do this
do it now
they won't do it they won't challenge
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi in her weakest
position yet
wants to be wants to be reelected
speaker and they have the leverage to
say
no to her and they won't they won't no
because i
look say what you will about nancy
pelosi but she's shrewd she
she's she's a ruthless politician she
knows the game she's been in washington
for a long time
she's got a lot of money she's got a lot
of money in her super pac
and she she can single-handedly funnel
millions of dollars which happened in my
race by the way
you know yeah she she funneled 1.2
million dollars
of of dark super pac money into pa 17
against me
i i would argue that it didn't work uh
maybe maybe
maybe it worked enough but the mail in
voting work no
no well the mail in the building worked
real well for the democrats you know uh
and oh and
oh so so you want you want to hear you
want to hear the latest on this yeah
what's going on so
the last time i was on the show we
talked about how there were 13 000
mystery
mail-in ballots that were infused into
my race the day after election day we
don't know where they came from
now this number of male-ins republican
democrat independent other
they're not projections we know what
that number is and we knew what that
number was on election day and we knew
what it was on election night
on election night there was no honest
mathematical path for my opponent to win
period end of story
news outlets had called the race leader
mccarthy called me to congratulate me
anyway you cut it there was gonna be a
two percentage point victory for me
right it was it was over mccarthy called
you at the exact moment that the ballot
dumps were happening the day after
election day at night wow and so
for five weeks we've been asking
allegheny county
where did these 13 000 ballots come from
now they they were dropped in two
successive dumps one at four
one of four thousand votes one of nine
thousand votes they were all for conor
lamb democrat
almost exclusively for biden and land
right where did they come from where did
they come from we've been asking them
for we've been asking allegheny county
for weeks
um we never got a response from
allegheny county
uh we had a great we had a real great
reporter in pittsburgh pennsylvania she
asked um
finally got a response in like the first
week of december and you want to know
what the
where are these 13 000 ballots what's
the chain of custody their answer was
mr parnell had a representative at our
facility
and signed out at 6 58 p.m before the
work was completed
and i said that's like first of all they
didn't answer the question
that's like the police officer saying to
a shoplifter sir did you steal those
groceries and this shoplifter shrugging
his shoulders and saying well the
cashier was off
they didn't answer the question they're
just they're just
brazenly laughing in our faces at this
and
my gosh if you we can't even talk about
it without your show getting we can't
even talk about
any of this stuff without getting banned
or disputed on social media
but i'm living this every single day and
look this isn't about me
like my god look being a representative
of of the people
by and for the people in congress would
have been in honor of a lifetime and
take it seriously
um but you know i had a pretty good life
before running for congress i take a
pretty big pay cut going into congress
so my point my point is this this is not
about conor lamb and me this isn't about
joe biden and trump
this is about we talked about the
democrats in the radical left
controlling every cultural institution
whether it's the media
entertainment uh education youtube
button youtube
social media big tech and now tim
they control the ballot box this is a
problem
and so we have we we've got to work out
the kinks in this election i don't it
doesn't matter
god it doesn't matter where the chips
fall and i would even be willing to say
that look 2020
people voted in good faith let's keep
2020 as is but we have
to fix and reform the system going
forward otherwise no one is going to
have faith and i know where you're going
to go with this
where am i going to because even if we
say 2020 was this was fubar
right 2020 was real messed up even if we
get a positive ruling from the supreme
court and the supreme court says yeah
act 77 is unconstitutional
2020 was jacked up but fix it going
forward you're gonna have 50
of the state of pennsylvania saying wait
what the election in pennsylvania was
unconstitutional and illegal in 2020 and
you're forcing me to accept it yep
so this is why i say this is a
constitutional crisis because even if
so say you say 2020 is messed up we're
moving forward like deal with it
50 of the people are going to not accept
it but then on the flip side of that you
say act 77 is unconstitutional and every
mail-in ballot that's sent in under that
unconstitutional system is getting
thrown out
that's also explosive because those
people cast their ballots in good faith
we went to the court tim which is
precisely how our system of government
is designed
to help us provide to help us give a
remedy to what we believe is a
constitutional crisis
because we got to have some clarity on
this election and every election moving
forward
and what point what you wanna you don't
know what i think is gonna happen next
oh tell me i think uh democrats are
gonna win in georgia
and then joe biden's gonna come gonna
become president and then they're going
to
pack the supreme court maybe maybe
because you might get
you might get like a mansion democrat
who's like i refuse to allow this
yeah but uh the reason why i think
they're going to win in georgia is
because
what i've often said is trump's not on
the ballot and people don't like the
republican party
they like trump and they like the new
wave of trump republicans
this it's a smaller group relatively
political establishment
but the runoff in georgia is on january
5th
on january 6th alex jones many others
say they're going to be in dc with 10
million people
yeah how many people from georgia are
going to pack their bags on the fifth
to drive perhaps not vote in georgia
exactly i know it's it's concerning for
sure that that can't happen though
tim i mean you're right look look let's
say let's war game this if the democrats
win in georgia
i think without question they will try
to pack the court yep
don't believe me this isn't what i think
they've said it they're going to
make two more states would probably be
democrat senators representing those who
are going to do a dc and puerto ric and
puerto rico
they're going to probably ditch the
electoral college again don't believe me
they've said it that would require that
would i think that would require
two-thirds ratification
so that they can't they're going to try
to do it but it won't matter
i don't i don't think you know i think
they've already changed the rules beyond
the election yeah i see what you mean it
won't matter yeah yeah look
the fact that they've done universal
mail-in voting
they've obliterated the chain of custody
for our election system they've ripped
security away from it
nancy pelosi wanted to get rid of voter
id they want
no security in their elections while
they screamed that we had insecure
elections for four years
and listen every pundit in at least in
the state of pennsylvania
the general sentiment is well democrat
in the white house republicans pick up
seat
in the off year right that's just always
been the historical trend what the party
that holds the white house the opposite
party picks up seats that year
but in the state of pennsylvania i don't
think the people realize the paradigm
shift that happened in 2020 there was
something called with as part of acts 77
called the automatic opt-in so during
the highest presidential voter turnout
in our nation's history
the democrats sent out something like
two plus million mail-in ballots if you
got a ballot application and you check
the automatic opt-in you get a ballot
sent to you
for every election until the day that
you die and if you're a democrat
probably after that as well but my my
point is
you the the idea that all of those
people
all of those democrats are going to get
ballots in the off psych and the off
cycle right
so they're feasibly feasibly they could
have a presidential voter turnout in a
mid-cycle in the state of pennsylvania
democrats only get elected with low
information voters
and i'm not saying that to disparage
your average democrat voter
but the fact that you've had democrats
talking about lowering the voting age to
16
is all the proof i need to say democrats
survive off of low information voters
people who aren't
so listen why do why do they want
universal mail in voting
well the left says to make it easier for
people to vote
should someone who has no idea what
they're voting for or who they're voting
for vote
my personal opinion no that's why i
don't like
we talked about quite a bit getting rid
of the d and
democrat republican getting rid of
parties on ballots imagine you got you
got a
flyer in the mail or imagine you go to
vote and you see conor lamb sean parnell
no democrat no republican just the names
the only people are gonna get the votes
are the people who are like i like sean
parnell or i like conor lamb
now what happens is you get a bout in
the mail and they go democrat
they don't know what they're voting for
they don't know why they're voting for
it and that's what democrats thrive on
we can't function if people just are
saying i don't know party
boop and they're not really voting for
anything other than team
then you end up with people who sell you
out to say china
and that's what we're headed towards i
don't you know what man i think the
democrats
this was their uh their reckless abandon
their desperate attempt to get enough
votes to beat trump
by waking as like waking many people to
politics getting them as active as
possible and angry as possible and now
we're all sitting
sitting here watching this relief bill
this ridiculous omnibus spending bill
everybody basically hates it everybody's
democrats hate it left
the left has said it conservatives say
that trump supporters hate it
they're they're they're throwing it in
our faces and laughing
so at this point i think the
establishment is
rather content mitch mcconnell is
already telling other senators not to
support trump on january 6.
uh you know don't don't do it he's
already
planning to override trump's veto trump
wants to veto the defense spending bill
well the republicans never had his back
they were only forced to have his back
because they knew that trump had the
support of the people well let me tell
you man
i think that's a huge look if if that's
the case if what you say is true
you know it'd be a huge mistake for any
republican in the house or the senate to
to run away or distance themselves from
the president he is
by far the most popular president in our
nation's history period
and and no i don't include joe biden in
that count because i'm sorry
look you could say what i i don't want
to get you in trouble on youtube or
whatever so i
i just i don't believe that he got 80
million votes the guy
the guy the guy never left his basement
he doesn't inspire anybody he did not
have a single message he can't string
together a single coherent sentence
there and and this idea of of widespread
voter fraud i disagree with it
i disagree with that i think i think the
fraud was very surgical
and if you look at the the red waves
happened everywhere
except for in areas that dem in counties
the democrats
absolutely had to win it was a zero-sum
game look at john james in michigan
look at derrick van orden navy seal in
wisconsin those two guys
lost me and pa 17 in the areas that
democrats
had to win and counties that they had to
win
to carry key battleground states they
want red wave
everywhere else in allegheny county the
president didn't lose the state of
pennsylvania
in philadelphia right that's not where
he lost he lost the state of
pennsylvania
in allegheny county where joe biden had
the second highest voter turnout
ever to lyndon b johnson in 1964
but in it and by the way by the way joe
biden got a couple thousand fewer votes
than linda b johnson in 1964 but
in 1964 allegheny county was 30 percent
more popular
there there is a very easy
simple explanation the media had been
screaming orange man bad nonsense that's
correct and then
they launched universal mail and voting
and so what i was saying was
in the month or two leading up to the
election you're gonna have this is
really funny i don't know if i don't
know
who said this to me i said you're gonna
have a parent the male and ballots are
gonna come into the house
and they're gonna go to their kids who
are like you know 18 20 and they're
gonna be like did you vote yet
you gotta vote you gotta vote for the
democrat and the kids who book i don't
care mom
and then i think it was maybe michael
malus who said no it's gonna be the way
around the college kids come home
and go to their parents and go we got
our belts you gotta vote and you gotta
vote for the democrats and the parents
go sure fine whatever
i think one of the reasons why we see
many of these votes were justified to
nobody else was because these people
don't vote they were like orange man bad
have a nice day
well look a coup a couple things like
let's just say let's see let's just even
say there was
let's just he said there was no fraud
right none whatsoever i still
bill barr said there was well of course
there was there there was fraud right
there was but bill barr said not enough
to affect the outcome
this was a new statement look look yeah
look my point is
let's just pretend that there was none
this is still not a free and fair
election you had the media
parroting non-stop lies about the
president
every single day the mainstream media
most in the media
and then you had big tech centering
stories that would have probably
made people switch their vote from joe
biden
to donald trump the hunter biden story
is a prime example of that he had the
oldest newspaper in the country right
the new york post
come out with a story that was perfectly
vetted fact checked perfectly you had
tony babaliski come out the media
ignored it 100 like something like 10 of
the people
who learned about this after the fact
said hey if they knew about this hunter
biden story going into november 3rd they
probably would not have voted for for
joe biden
and that right there in and of itself is
enough to switch
the outcome of the election so the
democrats control the cultural
institutions
and yeah and so yeah it's it's it's a
problem and now now
now with with act 77 in in the mail-in
ballots specifically in pennsylvania
they control the ballot box too dude you
have secret
ballot counting days after the election
was done
oh november 5th and 6th they're still
counting on this foreign proprietary
voter
machines canadian well canadian
corporation built this
i don't i proprietary voting machine
that counts and sees i don't know
anything about days after they need to
know how many they need
no no it's insane the voting machine the
problem with the the voting machines is
not that they're counting in secret
there there's proper tabulation on these
things the problem is that
when trump campaign and others sued they
were they were
the lawsuits were thrown out on
procedural grounds the problem is
that they were proper improper it's that
we don't know in errors well we don't
know anything no there's no transparency
well that's that's a lack of
transparency i should say that is
in arizona when they filed subpoenas for
the voting machines to actually get the
forensic analysis
you can see the vote counts you can see
the signatures they're not doing it oh
they gave us one
that's like one of those no they clocked
it and they said we're going to court
and we're not going to follow the
subpoenas
they got subpoenaed and said f you we
won't listen and in georgia when trump
said we want a hard signature audit they
said
no and they did like these sam sample
audits
so every single time there's been
someone saying can we look at these
machines it's been a
no and the one time we did in antrim
county
the report came out saying widespread
the mission
they claimed in this report there were
intentional errors in like 68 percent
to force adjudication so an election
official could choose where the vote
goes
that's the problem so yeah transparency
i would tell you
can i i'll tell you what happened very
simply in the state of pennsylvania
right there are all sorts of issues with
this election
you're looking at changes that were made
in the middle of the game
right unconstitutional changes to our
election code and to voting
in the middle of the game right the
secretary of state in the state of
pennsylvania
said we're going to remove the signature
verification for ballots we're going to
move any
of her mail in balance we're going to
remove the postmark requirement for any
mail-in ballot we're going to remove any
semblance of a deadline for a mail-in
ballot this was just a few weeks before
the election
so my point is they used dirty games
they used covid
to create chaos at the top they changed
the rules at the last minute at the top
right and then add to that at the next
tier down
you had you know what i what i call
zuckerberg money
that was invested in heavily democratic
counties like allegheny county i think
got 2.2 million dollars
i don't know it wasn't from zuckerberg
directly but it was
it was from a cell corporation or
something like that you can look it up
on on
google right now and find it to pay
election judges to boost their salaries
right this is this is all
just look it up i i don't think that
this is legal by the way but i haven't
seen lawsuits on it yet but you bank on
it there will be lawsuits on this
where they boosted the salaries of
judges of elections they created remote
satellite uh voting facilities where
people could just show up at like an ice
rink and cast their ballot
and they and they funded dropbox yeah
and they funded drop boxes
so and then they had and then and then
beyond that and
you had this this issue in beaver county
nursing homes that i've looked at like
granny harvesting ballot harvesting in
nursing homes um you had you have you
have ballots and issues of balance of
zero chains of custody in
in pa 17 that were cast that we had
stories and
affidavits from people who who have who
heard people voting twice
right they they mailed in a ballot and
then they voted provisional i mean there
are all sorts of issues with this
and i'm not all i'm saying right is that
we should look into it
this is the first this is the first time
that we've that we've used
an all mail-in system or no excuse
absentee system in the state of
pennsylvania
it's the first time it's ever happened
in the middle of a 100-year pandemic
is it not okay to think critically about
this and say let's look
into this a little bit to make sure that
everything went
as it was supposed to go because every
ballot that was cast illegally
cancels out a ballot of someone who
showed up on election day to vote
there's no political willpower
there's some there's there's listen it's
like i was it's like i was saying the
democrats will come into the
into congress and propose a bill to burn
down the house
and republicans will say only burn down
the kitchen i think we need
instead of arguing how about we don't
burn down the house they say well we'll
negotiate with you on what you're asking
for
what what upsets me is that how is it
the responsibility of the citizen to
prove
these things is it not the
responsibility of the government to
prove to the people
that their elections are free we are the
government yes and is it not the
responsibility of the media to be a
watchdog for the people and ask
real questions yes and this is why i'm
pretty pessimistic on where we go next
because the media in this country is
they're democrats that that's true i
mean the the overwhelming majority of
all of these big media companies
are pro-democrat they would not report
on hunter biden even though it's
probably one of the biggest
stories of the decade or longer and so
they're not watchdogs they're advocates
and so you have advocates and we are
headed towards california-style
one-party rule
you know you know what i love about
california a year or so ago probably two
years ago
i was reporting on the rise of medieval
diseases in california
because their their government has
failed
and it's basically democrat super
majority in all of these big cities
and they saw a bubonic plague and like
typhus
all of that happening just before covet
happened they were the worst prepared
place
their policies were failures and you
look at new york which was the worst
affected and once again democrat
controlled
so i would think it's not democrat it's
a corporatist issue their corporatist
masked with that democrat phrase of
course
they chose to ally with that party for
their moment they're cronies
and it's republicans too it's just that
when trump came into the republican
party
some people sided with him and new
people have now gotten elected
and would have been one of someone like
yourself a lot of the new republicans
that are coming in
are good regular people and supporters
of the president and the working-class
individuals
populists i suppose but there's too many
i mean the democratic party is almost
exclusively like crony corporate
types and the republican party is a lot
of them so i don't know
i don't know how you change that we
gotta go outside the system
there's no fixing that system from
within we need an external
blockchain voting system that goes in
tandem something that works in tandem
with the broken system
so that you can outshine it i i see what
you're saying but listen i just had to
explain to somebody
how the government printing 35 of all
u.s dollars in 10 months right was
taking away their bodies i'll tell you
what civil disobedience they're not
paying that deficit
they don't understand what that means
and the little response is
what do you mean the government's giving
me six hundred dollars
these people who are voting who are are
being given mail-in ballots
universally just appearing in their
mailbox they're going oh i get i get six
hundred dollars you're using an
anecdotal argument you know some stupid
people that doesn't mean we can't work
outside the system
that is nothing what are you talking
about you're saying this anecdotal idiot
that's like i got 600 bro that means
that everyone they're too stupid to
create a new system i don't think people
understand that the lockdown
is destroying their power and
transferring their wealth to the wealthy
i think they're capable of understanding
that yeah
yes and so the problem right now is you
creating a voting system won't change
the fact that people don't
understand how they are getting ripped
off by crony
that's the fake representation i'm not
trying to solve the problem of people
getting ripped off with the new voting
system they're different problems
we're talking about why did you bring it
up because we need something that's
transparent
when we're talking about voting and how
to fix the system so people like sean
could actually run for office and win
right so so for instead of you changing
the subject i was talking about the fact
that we have universal mail-in voting
corrupting the system
by putting votes into the hands of
people who have not been properly
informed and educated because the media
class is controlled by the democratic
party
so instead of being told here's why you
should vote for this if you like this
this is for you if you like this is for
you
they're saying this person's a fascist
you have to vote for this
and then regular people who don't care
don't pay attention who have been
inundated for it for four years about
the evil cheeto dictator get about in
their mailbox and go yeah trump is bad i
guess well i like your idea of taking r
d off
but i don't think you can ever stop you
know manipulation
media manipulation we just gotta roll
with that well we
the the problem is we have a corrupt uh
uh big tech
is is the main issue it if we had an
honest sensor free social media then
people would start to get
upset with seeing fake news and then
seek out alternatives
you can't do that because google will
ban you you can't even
talk about some of these lawsuits
because google will ban you
i mean we can't even say i can't even
say words in a certain sequence for
youtube
i know it's hilarious well i mean and
the thing is is that these aren't this
isn't like just me speculating like
you know release them yeah you're
involved in a lawsuit i i'm seeing it
i'm involved in a lawsuit i'm seeing it
firsthand
this is not just me and this is not this
is
this is not about me winning an election
or trump winning election this is about
democrats and republicans having faith
in the system
and you know democrats right now i mean
i i find it funny when a lot of like
establishment democrats or well
everybody basically in the state of
pennsylvania from the governor to the
attorney general to the
to the secretary they all attack me now
but they they attack me as if i'm a
republican and what i'm doing is that
for the benefit of the republican party
no
that's not true no that doesn't matter
but it works the thing is for me is that
i'm actually fighting for democrats too
now because they might find themselves
on the receiving end
of unconstitutional mandates from from a
republican governor someday that they
might not like very much and it's
it's we got to get rid of i think we
really got to get rid of
party lists on belts i think that would
be a big first step to solving this
if somebody goes in if they get if they
get a ballot they might know trump is
bad so they might not vote for him right
but if they get a ballot that says conor
lamb sean parnell they don't know who
you are then
what do they vote for right now people
are voting on party lines and that's the
problem because
you end up if you do that over a long
enough period of time
we just had a transgender satanist
anarchist
win the republican primary in new
hampshire for sheriff because people
just saw the republican and voted for
and once they found out who they voted
for they freaked out like i can't
believe i voted for this and i was like
that's interesting that's your vote i
didn't i heard something i saw something
about that but
yeah that's interesting so i think we
need
that getting rid of parties will be a
good step because people might just go
in
i guess the problem there is people
might just vote for the first name you
know they might
and then you know whatever's on the
ballot so we have to figure out it's
tough it really is well i don't
look i'll tell you this i don't know i
don't know if solutions the problem but
um
i'm i'm fairly fairly pessimistic to the
point where i'm
going to oh you are going to be going to
be buying a large
large property in west virginia and uh
uh
you know now to be completely honest you
know i don't make it sound like we're
buying this property in west virginia
because we're
you know freaking out and fleeing or
thing we're doing it so that we can have
atvs and like film videos and do you
know skateboard jumps and stuff like
that
but uh i don't want to live in a city
that's true you know i don't want to be
anywhere near these cities right now
because the riots
because the potential for unrest and i
don't know what's going to happen come
january 6 but people are going to get
angry yeah i think people
look i i i don't disagree that we live
at a a highly divided time i don't
disagree that that maybe there are some
some rough times ahead uh but i don't
think
that yeah i'm still gonna fight like
hell for the commonwealth of
pennsylvania for this country
i'm still going to fight to represent
the people whether
you have a rank as a captain in the
military or title of congressman or
senator or governor none of that titles
don't matter
okay but fighting for this country and
fighting for really our children to make
sure that they inherit a country that's
rich with opportunity regardless of
their political views that's worth
fighting for for me and
yeah you know i'm going to stay in the
fight for that reason and that reason
alone
um right on and so i i'm not going to
run from it you know
i'm like i'm like a week away from
painting my face blue and riding a horse
on harrisburg to lift these lockdowns
i'm so sick and tired of it because i'm
sick and tired of
seeing people struggle yeah i'm sick i
never thought in my whole life that you
see food lines in my hometown
every single week by the thousands
before thanksgiving miles long
it's not okay the government does not
have a right to deny your ability to
make a living
dude in this technology era where we can
where we have access to
vertical farms and electricity almost at
will
why is there so much poverty why is
there so much debt owed to the
the private bank the federal reserve now
why why
what the the issue of poverty is that
it's relative if you're comparing
somebody
who makes less than thirteen thousand
dollars a year but as a refrigerator and
air conditioning clean running water
to somebody in like 1900 who was poor
it's dramatically different that person
would be considered very wealthy by that
by those standards
the the saying goes that uh a person
living in poverty in the united states
today
has better dental care than rockefeller
did when he was you know
the richest guy but they're they're in
debt well i would i would i would say i
would also say that
everything that you said is true of
course poverty is relative but i would
also say that many of the people that
are in these food lines today
were forced into poverty by their
government yeah and then
many of these people who were in food
lines today because governor wolf
never never appropriated took the
appropriated funds to invest in our
unemployment system
got shunted into the calcified
bureaucracy
of our unemployment system in the state
of pennsylvania we're never able to
access the unemployment funds for them
so not only were they forced
in to poverty by our government
in the state of pennsylvania they
weren't able to access their own
benefits because of the government so
now
people find themselves in food lines
because of the government now i'm just
opposed to that
i'm i'm opposed to too much government
intervention
in our lives is a bad thing uh i think
people if left to their own devices uh
you know again
we can protect ourselves from recovery
and we can allow people to make a living
people need to be responsible for
themselves but uh we should we should go
to super chat hey wait before we go to
super are you gonna open my gift i am
right before we go to super chats right
now oh i put you on the spot you don't
have to open i don't know i was
i was going to do it right before we
started chats you just beat me to it
okay
so now he talked about this gift ahead
of time and he listed all these cool
things that he
that that he thinks it might be and it
was none of those things and now i'm
really worthy you're not gonna like
anybody
it's gonna be awesome so uh sean bought
got me a present i guess
yeah yeah is that a five thousand pages
of uh five thousand
dollars bill and i didn't i didn't wrap
it
i didn't wrap it melanie wrapped it
cause she's like literally the best
rapper ever that's right but you said
it's something i asked for yes it's
something that you asked for it's gonna
be really awful and embarrassing and
gonna get advantageous
no god no no but it's it's i now i feel
like it's gonna be totally underwhelming
let's see the wrappings i'm sure it's
great
but yeah it's not just that that's just
the box underneath it so you have to
like go
like open the box it's christmas
everybody
remind me of ralphie from the christmas
story well i don't want to there's not
going to be a pink bunny but there's a
label on the front that's what he's
trying to oh oh oh yeah
[Laughter]
oops what is this oh open it up this is
a pretty good present open them up
this is a pretty good present we got
here
maybe a little bit self-serving yes
perfect but here but here's the deal
these these are all
these are all my books and so for the
people that are watching for the people
that are watching
you guys didn't even know that i really
wrote books before i came on the show i
don't come on to this program and hockey
my product right
what's all that war about these are all
my books
back me up here like i have never come
on the show i don't talk a product on
your show
of course yeah you bring me a present
you told me to bring it
yeah i showed up i i come out you're
here and there's a box i'm like oh
and you're like i got a gift from like
cool and then you're like it's something
you asked for i'm like great it is
and then i'm like i'll open on the show
and you're like oh if you want to i'm
like all right this is a very clever
move
it was not that it wasn't like that you
told you told me
look if i wanted look if i were going to
hawk my book on
on i would have brought it the first
time you didn't even know i wrote
fiction
yeah not until i don't talk about this
stuff so my point i'm just thinking
you're like the last time i was here
you're like you should bring you should
bring your books you should bring your
books
yeah i did so you got me your books
that's great
is my is my non-fiction book but these
are all my fiction books and we talk
about the left controlling levers of of
power and cultural institutions
well these books like one true patriot
is
is my latest book right and and these
books i write about the threats
that that like the threats that we face
today right
that like so they're in in one true
patriot this massive cyber attack that
penetrated all of our government
institutions and and the department of
the are all five branches of the
military the office of the president
that i wrote about that happening in one
true patriot months ago
wow so i try to look at like the
greatest threats that we face
and put them in a story an accessible
story that people can like
have fun with right now yeah wow this is
the franchise of books
what's the non-fiction one about if you
like guns and stuff and tech which i
know you do
like there's lots of cool guns in in the
fiction in the face is that one about
your platoon
yeah this is this is this is the book uh
outlaw platoon came out
in 2012. i started writing it in 2007.
but that book became like an instant new
york times bestseller it was in 10
countries i think it just came out in
china
um is it about your platoon yeah it's
about my platoon 400.
were you guys forced to like disobey
orders and become outlaws or something
that's what's happening i've gotten that
i've gotten that question before
uh but no that's just the name of my
platoon oh that's awesome but yeah
so like it i was thinking like the power
of of tim's audience is kind of amazing
like if if one true patriot or any like
can you imagine like if one true patriot
becomes a bestseller and i'm already a
best-selling author so i don't i'm not
saying like this is like a
thing that i need but i think that i
would make you
a main character i just put you in the
next book i think i will oh good idea
i'll make you the bad guy yes i'll make
you whatever you want in in the next
book you could be
you could be in the alpha program what's
the alpha program
oh well the alpha so the i so i kind of
created the oh that's right that's right
you told me about last time yeah so like
there were all these times in
afghanistan where we get these missions
to go after these targets and like
we know exactly where the guy was well
hey i'm just let's just take my platoon
over there let's get this guy right now
like
we can get him i can see him he's
standing right there but you have to go
up through all these layers of
bureaucracy before you get clearance
by the time you clearance he's gone he's
gone so i said well what if
we developed a program called the alpha
program that was not
that didn't have to adhere to any sort
of bureaucracy that gave the president a
third option between diplomacy and war
right all-out war and in this case he'd
lean on the alphas now
we used to have that we used to have
that yeah so in the day
so a long time ago yeah so the the alpha
program was was created in the wake of
the
oss after world war ii there are nine
alphas
in the alpha program each each assigned
to a different geographic area of the
globe
right and this these books follow
eric steele who is the youngest alpha
part of the program is
he's he's the president's favorite and
so the president he's like the
president's fixer he sends them into
you know really hot situations to fix
global problems
and so it's sort of like a tom clancy
vince flynn
blend of of a you know military
political thriller
and so you need video games and movies
well before i started running for
political office that's exactly what i
was trying to do
out there working with some of these
hollywood producers to to you know make
a netflix
series and do all this cool sexy stuff
um
you know writing stories and and fiction
is always something i've been passionate
about but
i did not do this to hawk this product
on your show i hope you know that i oh
no i load the i didn't even mention the
fact that i wrote fiction when i first
came here yeah
he did not well now we'll we'll have him
chilling and we'll read something you're
actually going to read them because i'm
going to quiz you
do it you're not going to read them to
be honest probably not you got to do
your book on tape
but but listen listen uh i'm i you know
we had a
we had alex jones on the show and he
asked me to come on his show and i was
like
and people were like tim why won't you
just at least lie to people i'm not
going to do it like i'll tell you right
now
the reason why i probably won't read
them is because i'm working all the time
well i know you work non-stop
you're the hardest worker i know have
you read them done like a book on uh
audiobooks uh no i mean i don't read any
of those actually or do you gotta do
awesome probably read this i'll probably
read out level two
it looks awesome yeah yeah the the the
like because this is
this the kind of stuff the perspective
the real world stuff
for you know fiction and entertainment
stuff
for the most part i'll play some video
games is like in some downtime if i need
to like
you know get out but this is the kind of
thing i'll probably like read at night
just because it's like
actual real world conflict war and stuff
that's yeah
yeah that's the important stuff you
asked me to bring them so i brought them
and
man they were wrapped up but i'll tell
you this uh uh they will be read
absolutely almost immediately
by people here yeah so man of war is the
first one all out war is the second
page okay yeah one true you don't have
they're all standalone stories but have
the same character and i'm working on
book four now
which is all about china and all about
uh the next level virus that that comes
like like covet 19 was really just an
economic and political did you see
songbird the movie
no coven22 or whatever oh god well i'm
not i don't want it so i don't call it
covid because
if i ever if i have the word covert one
more time uh
i can't but well let's uh let's read
some super chats because we got people
who have
asked some questions all right let's see
what's uh student of history says
the cops aren't praetorian guard
victorian guard liked offing the emperor
and auctioning the position would be
uh auctioning the position would be more
like mercenaries pay the gold and they'd
do whatever you ask regardless of morals
that was the varangian guard that was
the byzantine cadre
let's see uh talbot link says i'm alive
today exactly because i disregarded two
orders
and was proven right while enlisted all
branches have troops that do the same
spread around
that's that's it that's exactly that's
it did you ever encounter a situation
where the defy orders
no no um no
no because anybody who did all right yes
yeah i mean
one of my friends dakota meyer was
awarded the medal of honor for it whoa
really what do you do i've heard of him
before oh dakota meyer is an amazing guy
i mean dakota meyer i mean you read it
just google him read a story won the
medal of honor in afghanistan
what's the gist of it well i mean he ran
in and out of fire
yeah he ran into a fire to save people's
lives like five or six times
he tells the story or not to do it or
whatever or yeah
yes they he's on jocko willing's podcast
and explains the whole thing it's
insane yeah about going into it he was
on that podcast i think
i don't know what episode he was he was
like but i was episode 192 i think he
was on
before that but i talk about yeah
dakota's an amazing guy but he got
awarded
the medal of honor for disobeying orders
and i mean i
for the for the most part i mean i had
great commanders in afghanistan and in
the field i was the one
issuing commands you know yeah as the
commander and so
um i mean there were there there were i
didn't i didn't encounter any of those
situations right
that's good wonder racing llc says sean
parnell one of the last great american
politicians and he puts in quotes left
in western pa and our great state of pa
keep fighting sean millions of patriots
are behind you
i will i will keep fighting i will you
can bank on that
andrew lance says tim as a typical
christian voter all we want from our
reps
is for them to stop the left at the
federal level we don't want them to
invoke intrusive legislation
we want to be left alone from federal
government your mandatory gun analogy
angers me to no end it's not my analogy
it was actually michael malus
and the point was that the the left will
impose things
but the right doesn't argue on a
right-wing argument's terms
so i'm talking about a better example is
the lockdown
the democratic governor shut everything
down destroy the economy republican
then they'll say okay now that we've
destroyed everything you're relying on
us and we'll give you a check
instead of republicans saying open
everything back up and stop
suppressing people's rights they say
well hold on let's give them less money
that's not an argument against what the
democrats have already done i think a
better analogy for the gun thing would
be like
you know barack obama says you have to
buy health care otherwise you get fined
it's basically you know criminal in some
some capacity then republicans should
have said okay
if you want that then you have to pass
this bill that says
to a shall not be infringed period in
any capacity something to defend the
rights of people there's never
there's rarely i should say arguments
from republicans saying here's what we
are asking for and we want
if if what you're saying president trump
right right exactly trump trump does
that
you're saying that uh people want to be
left alone from federal government
okay where are the republicans right now
putting bills forward saying the federal
government
you know and and government the
government in general shouldn't be
locking down and suppressing people's
rights
we just don't have it did you hear that
you heard that yeah you have it in me
you have it in me right i'm saying it
yeah well no so we we haven't you're
absolutely right we have it in trump
right and that's why trump won because
finally
working-class people and conservatives
are tired of getting politicians
who all they would do is wag the finger
at democrats and then give them what
they want
that's right someone told me republicans
what do they do they roll over for
democrats that's that's what they're
known for the establishment republicans
a ghost says system is broken because
people only know how to talk but not how
to act
the first amendment was written when
people believed in things like chivalry
atlas will still shrug well
yeah he's right deeds not words right uh
you know yeah jack bailey says
the bible says that in the last seven
years before the rapture that one of the
nations that
one of the nations that come about is
represented
by a lion with eagle's wings and the
eagle's wings shall be plucked and the
lion will stand as a man with a heart
really i'll look into it paige npa says
sean what are your thoughts on a federal
on a federal single subject rule similar
to that in article three section three
of the pa constitution
oh my god really i have no idea i don't
know how to answer that question
what's what's do you know what article
three is no i have to look at the pa
constitution i mean yeah
i am not i feel like i'm failing this
this person's
question you know i i'm not i am i am
not
an attorney i rely on attorneys to to
advise me on things and then i develop
my own arguments based on that legal
advice but i am a
knuckle dragging warrior i i i'm not uh
an attorney and i won't even pretend to
be one on your on your on your show
all right although i need you right you
know what you know what though
i i will get an answer for that i i will
get an answer for that question and i
and tim i'll get it to you on your next
podcast so i i don't know uh but i'll
tell
i'll tell that person who who asked the
question what's the name article three
uh uh uh page from page uh i will get
paid page npa
page i will get an answer for you i
don't know but i will get an answer we
got
we got a comment from someone who really
doesn't like you you want to hear it yes
it's a big super chat too he's he
basically said um
pound sign at symbol 1k you parnell so i
guess he's saying fu parnell
it's obvious that you're a hack i hope
that you're your quote political career
ends up with you humiliated and exposed
as the leech that you apparently are
leech what am i leeching off of i don't
know you apparently write books and
you're already doing pretty well for
yourself so
i get that a lot yeah that's right i
mean
yeah okay merry christmas dude
all right let's see wandering mage says
tim could you imagine if entire
republican counties decided to become
autonomous zones with the declaration
that they would not pay federal taxes to
protest the nonsense political decisions
what do you think for a super chat um
it's very simple
if any large group of people decides to
do something
they instantly win that's exactly right
government
so derives its power from the consensus
the governed yes so if
every single person in the country just
went about their lives like normal
there would not be a lockdown because
you'd have you'd have cuomo being like
why won't anybody do anything
and no one listens to him if nobody
listens to cuomo he's just a raving
lunatic standing on the street corner
screaming about how he's supposed to be
in power
if all of these republican counties said
we're autonomous they would be
and what's the government going to do
imagine this i mean how many republican
counties are there like 3 000 or
whatever
because they're less populated than the
democrat tightly packed ones
what's going to happen the national
guard going to get deployed the irs is
going to get deployed to all these
different places
i'm not saying it's a it's a good thing
i think breaking up this country or
civil war anything like that would
result
in the u.s becoming extremely weakened
and then china is going to be
laughing all the way to subverting and
destroying the country faster than they
already are
so we really you know i've heard a lot
of people say peaceful divorce
and i get it because they don't want
violence and stuff but that means we're
already in deep trouble
it's only peaceful if both people want
it too i don't want that i want to
preserve
this great country this country is great
and and by the way like
diverse political opinions is also good
like discourse and debate is also good
like that guy that said fu to me okay
that's great
um i don't mind that i can take it i put
myself out in the public sphere if
people don't like what i have to say
they're
more than entitled to say that but the
difference is i won't censor them
because i disagree with them it's crazy
how like you know uh there are a lot of
people on the left who insult me for a
variety of reasons it's funny um
i get the same the young turks did a
segment basically calling me ugly
for like i don't for no reason either i
don't know that's how that's how they
it's how the radical left is that's what
they do they just attack they'd attack
you personally they attack you personal
life i mean we did this
we did a segment where i was citing
there's like five different studies that
show conservatives tend to be more
attractive than
than liberals and i was pointing out
that a feminist
explained this to me as a way to
describe privilege
somebody who's been attractive their
whole life has had an easier go of
things
and they think if it was easy for me
it's easy for you not realizing they've
had a
privilege in their life the young turks
decided to run the segment
making fun of me and calling me ugly but
then ultimately saying i was correct
it made no sense but here's the funny
thing the way they made fun of me is the
exact same way
the the hardcore trump supporters make
fun of me the thing that matters most
i literally don't care like i question i
so i question why the young turks would
do a weird segment where they agree with
me but then mock me like where's
what are you doing trump supporters who
are making fun of me and you know
calling me ugly or whatever it's like
okay like what am i gonna do about do i
supposed to cry i don't know well
i can't do anything about that it's
called ugly often i don't i don't see
that i don't think no it's
it was it was the the young turks was
because specifically because
i did something saying liberals were
ugly i guess yeah and so they wanted to
make an issue of it
yeah but the point the ultimate point is
why do people care so much about it you
know it's like you're gonna get hey
people are gonna you know i i go on i
can i if if i really wanna you know just
make sure i keep my ego in check all i
gotta do is open my twitter
notifications
yeah twitter notifications are rough
he's like dude if i wanted someone to
install me i'd hire like a
what would you call it an s m someone to
come whip you with the chain or
something
it's twitter i know it's it's it's right
mike g says to sean parnell great taste
gnr i'm wearing the same shirt today
also alex padilla became the first latin
rep in ca
and they're applauding this meanwhile
texas had its first rep in 1916.
[Laughter]
we got some spicy super chips i can't
read but they're basically saying
they you know civil war oh yeah and
they're literally saying it and that's
that that's the issue i'm saying of like
if conservatives are now spraying down
cops of pepper spray
you don't want look it's a quote from
joe rogan that goes viral that goes
viral all the time
where he said the guys who actually know
what war is like
and who experienced it are the ones
saying you don't want this we'll never
advocate for it
exactly exactly and and but in this
quote he says and it's these you know
it's like basically
anti-father screaming and demanding it
and as soon as they open that floodgates
they're going to regret it
well yeah those who those who've seen
the horrors of war
almost never advocate for it openly and
and by the way like
there i i've mentioned this before in
your podcast i i don't
this nation can be saved uh
and and i i would i would argue that
with great leadership
can pull us out of this thing you know
um
and so god i i hate to even i hate to
even
it bothers me that people feel so
distraught and hopeless that that's
right where their minds are right now
but i'm here on this program saying
don't give up hope
don't lose heart stay in the fight uh
america is worth fighting for
um and you know let's fight fight with
me hell if you're in pennsylvania stand
with me and fight with me
let's see army chief 2005 says thank you
for having this patriot on your show
uh what's the third time now yeah i know
man this is crazy and i know you're
always welcome to come and i didn't even
hawk my book until the third
time right christmas
it's a perfect time actually you know
you guys should check out his book if
it's the kind of stuff you like that's a
business tactic you jab jab right hook
so you just jab the company if your
viewers put one true patriot on the best
seller list man
you're going it you're going where can
they buy it but how do you do that how
do you get on the best seller list
oh oh so sell a lot right a couple a few
thousand books
really that's in a week that's it that's
a lot i mean like
you know the problem with fiction the
reason why it's so hard to make the best
seller list in fiction is because you're
going up against a guy like stephen king
who has three books at any given time on
the best sellers you know the 12th harry
potter world
oh yeah like they're so so yeah you've
got which one one true patriots that's
the latest one that's the one that just
came out
if this it's cause i'm working on the
next book now if your audience get
gets that book on on the bestseller list
i'll put tim and this entire podcast
you'll be a main character in all my
books moving forward have you seen jack
posobix
uh oh yeah yeah yeah so so i love what
he's doing there because
again it's not just yes yes
politics is downstream from culture
except
he so we brought some comics and i
pointed to the art of him holding the
gun
yeah with the weird attachment that's
some kind of suppressor
and he was like i know man like people
who people people who read this like
they know about guns they're probably
looking at it
i know the people that worked on that
jack is what jack is is great but the
people who
who work and i know that i know the
artists who worked on that comic as well
they're total pros like marvel and dc
yeah they're good yeah good right on all
right let's see we got here soul
invictus says could not disagree more he
says violence is necessary because
others will choose violence
you have no choice but to retaliate if
you have to do something horrible do it
quickly
don't force others to suffer well i
think the important thing there is
defense is is acceptable in terms of the
violence conversation
protecting yourself from someone who
means to do your harm is legally
like i mean and i would i would even go
i
yes in afghanistan you know we it's
what's so fascinating about th this
topic is that we never would have fired
our weapons in afghanistan
unless we were fi if we weren't fired on
first
the only time we ever shot our weapons
is when we were shot at first in
afghanistan outside of that we were
driving coloring books to kids and
building wells and humanitarian
assistants
the problem is we just got ambushed and
direct fire attacks
every time we left i can i can easily
you know disprove this comment on on you
know anyone advocating for violence
it's really simple it's the reason why
china isn't sending boats and planes and
storming the beaches and attacking
it's why they're using fifth
generational warfare because violence
isn't effective especially in the
information age
it makes people not like you they won't
listen to you and they'll resist you
the most effective thing you can do is
win them over through propaganda and
media manipulation that's fifth
generation
finance yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly it's
easier to give someone money
than it is to try and force them to do
something it's like hey i'll give you a
thousand dollars if you do it and people
might just be like okay
but the other thing too is when it comes
to what's going on with kovid
violence is totally like uh
antithetical no no no no what i want to
say is like it would have the opposite
intended effect
if everybody who's upset with the covet
lockdown just said
okay i'll go and open my business there
wouldn't be one it'd be over like
it's like this is what i explain to
people when i was little i'd have a
friend and i'd be like hey you want to
go skate
i can't i'm grounded and i'll go okay do
you want to go skate i can't i'm
grounded i'm like what does that mean
my parents told me i can't go outside
and and i would say this what would
happen if you go outside he's like
i'll get grounded again i'm like oh and
then what happens when they ground you
again and then you go outside again
and he's like well they walk into your
room and they take your tv
they yank it out of the wall they take
all your toys
you're comparing the governor of
pennsylvania to parents no what i'm
saying is
if the lockdowns are
like if you can't open your business
because someone said don't open your
business but you could literally walk
into your business and open the door
then there's no lockdown if if the kids
if if my kids are for some reason
watching this
or or your daughters are for some reason
watching this
if you're grounded if you're grounded
you're grounded yeah well so i was like
nobody's not violating the house no
one's leaving the house when i was like
15 and i'm telling my friends
the worst thing that's gonna happen is
they're gonna keep telling you can't go
outside but if you're grounded and you
can go outside
then grounding you doesn't do anything
does it if they're telling you
you're all locked down you can't open
your business and everyone says we're
gonna open our businesses
they can't they can come like audit you
and take take your money out of your
bank account well if
the individual they go after individuals
but if everyone at once does it exactly
the system changes that's exactly it if
people just said i'm
gonna non-violent civil disobedience and
i think the reason why people don't and
specifically
in this regard is because people want to
protect their fellow citizens
right and but my point is that we can do
both responsibly we can both
open up and protect public public health
it's possible nuke the ice caps
says and great name by the way left and
right now
now disowning the police everybody is
absolutely at their breaking point
when we get to this point we have to ask
why when they will not allow us to ask
why
there really isn't a choice left is
there merry xmas lady and gentlemen
merry christmas don't lose faith in the
police i have and i stand with them
and again this is this is a leadership
issue
you know if leaders stood up and said
keep your businesses open keep your
restaurants open please don't enforce
unconstitutional orders stand with the
people this problem and these lockdowns
would be over tomorrow
a lot of people mentioning that right
when we started the show trump said f
the covid relief bill so so awesome yeah
did he really say that did he really i
don't know
i mean it really wouldn't surprise me
especially at this point yeah christmas
rita hoe says good job on on pronouncing
fangfeng well it was because we had
china uncensored
and they told us how to pronounce
everyone says fang fang i think i said
fang fang
yeah it rhymes with a different word
yeah yeah that's why
that's why i went right there yeah the
civic nationalist says from the british
empire to the colonies merry christmas
one and all god save the queen
to quote the joker you get what you
effing deserve should have just paid
them taxes
i object here's the joke i made when you
have these uh these
electoral candidates republican party
hey wait a second he said we get what we
deserve didn't didn't
didn't the uk just lock down because of
some mutated street
you're the one missing out on christmas
and
they're expecting food shortages i know
it's tragic because the borders are just
shut
that's not good i know it's terrible
yeah they're done but
here's here's what i said when when
people you had these uh republican
electoral candidates
they so they're not the electors the
natural candidates for the republican
side
cast procedural votes so it's on record
in the event trump overturned some
elections
and you have the democrats saying
they're not legitimate votes and i'm
like
sure i understand in terms of the
constitutional process with the
electoral colleges the votes from these
aren't official and i'm sure when the
founding father signed the declaration
of
independence
sent it to you know to the king the king
looked at and said by what authority do
these any of these people have to say
they are no their country is independent
they're not because it's our country
and that's that's it it's all an issue
of confidence i'm certainly not saying
the republican electors are like
declaring defense anything like that
what i'm saying is if right now
everybody woke up
and they just said the gov the
government has no authority
it would have no authority now they
could go and try and enforce the law but
if literally
like i hear a lot of people saying like
tax strikes like the left talks about
this stuff too
yeah if nobody was paying taxes then
there would be an authority but it's an
issue of organizational power
and people pay taxes i think the issue
is you'll hear people say everyone
should stop paying taxes or whatever and
it's like
yeah but most people in this country
don't care and they're fine with paying
taxes
the problem is these lockdowns are
destroying the lives of regular people
who are on the break
at their breaking point and now this is
where we get things get you know crazy
that's when you got to be worried about
what people are going to start doing
all of it could end if we just lifted
these these
unsigned yeah special protections for
nursing homes
and for people who have uh you know
pre-existing conditions absolutely
and also direct resources to those
programs as well to protect those people
from a 99.7 recovery percent recovery
rate
further 99.99 survival rate this is it
across
the entire across every age group right
the world
the human world locked down shut down
their businesses for a virus with a 99.9
when i say 9
and what i said and i say like if
and again i i'm gonna i'm gonna say we
should definitely we should take it
seriously we should protect the
vulnerable i'm not i'm
gonna say it every single time because
i'm telling you some leftists will take
this out of context and attack me with
it later but
but if this virus were as bad
as some are making it out to be the
government would not have to mandate
people stay home
it's often so this one's uh this one's
funny have you guys heard about this new
signal that came out of proxima centauri
negative that was like so there's
something called the wow signal it was
you know we're scanning the
the space and we got this weird radio
signal well another one just happened we
got a super chat
the alien radio signal from proxima
centauri has been decoded
60 000 million votes for biden oh okay
unsurprisingly it took a few weeks to
get here mafu says type 6 if you're
going to dc on january 6th
there will never be a biden presidency
he says you know have you heard about
what's going on january 6th
you know alex jones put out a video
where he said 10 million people will
descend on dc will occupy dc
uh i don't know what to say to that i i
don't know anything about that
uh so that it's a big protest plan for
the day that the joint session is going
to happen
and um you know i've had some people hit
me up saying they're going to dc
that i don't think are particularly
politically active in that sense so i
wonder if there's going to be
i think there's going to be a really
massive protest
in dc on the 6 when the joint session's
supposed to happen we'll see
yeah we'll see daniel maxwell says peace
requires that all factions involved
desire peace
violence results when one faction
chooses to use force to get their way
and war results when one or more of the
remaining factions decide to defend
themselves
interesting yes
xd interactive says dc was appropriate
for government use
it can't be a state by the constitution
and that is not an amendment
it can't be changed at worst they could
give it back to virginia
that's that's the thing it's the it's
the when they say make dc that makes no
sense
the the reason why dc is federal
property is because the federal
government operates outside of the
states
and finding the founding fathers or at
the time the the federalists
didn't want one state to have control
over the jurisdiction the federal
government operated in
that's right i just think that the left
doesn't care about the constitution the
radical life does not care about
of course yeah the captain z says
southwestern pa here greene and
washington wouldn't take this stuff nor
are the count uh
counties that bear their names if there
is a divorce do it county by county not
state by state we have the food the
energy and the power plants
california actually has a lot of they
also had a council uh
a team working with them like ben
franklin john adams and they were
writing documents and new
new forms of like uh governance so that
they could not just destroy the system
but
create something new i have and actually
a lot of people uh don't know this i
could be wrong about this but there was
some inspiration from
native american uh governance because
they were they were
a lot of them were tribal and they had
certain voting processes that the
founding fathers looked at we're like we
could incorporate that somehow that's
interesting
uh eddie johnson oh we have a correction
here he says it's mossy rock not mossy
brook oh
went to a restaurant to support them and
they had customers coming from three or
four hours away to support them wow yep
very
rock washington interesting bernard kim
says
like the idea of obfuscating parties of
candidates but people will just look on
google the party without doing much more
research past that but
it's still better than nothing because
then you get low information voters
going i don't know
and then they don't vote and you don't
want people like could you
we can't have people voting based on
just party because that doesn't mean
anything
it certainly doesn't change much right
right yeah
all right let's see damian harcat says
tim you say me we must resit
resist yet any and all resistance is
seen as crazy and extreme
if we're basically being told to our
face to die and starve
while uh terrorists on the left run free
what what
what do we do nonviolent disobedience
people hated the riots
the riots caused a massive drop in
support for black lives matter and the
democrats
are freaking out because of it just
showing up and
you know success success is the best
revenge i guess i say right
patronize your small business show up to
restaurants and order
food like help them help them get by
help them see this crisis through
yeah that's just just it like help your
neighbor
you know be there for people in their
hour of need
all right let's see we got here a bunch
of uh comments that are saying
things i can't read on youtube but
youtube will allow them type it in
because they meet they they don't like
context algorithms don't know context
skeleton king
says sean when when do we occupy
harrisburg
i just said i was ready to ride on a
horse and paint my face blue
they're ready i know i know i
you know i uh gosh i'm
i'm close to it i'm i'm almost there i'm
almost there
i'm almost there do it and take pictures
renee villarreal says just got all seven
of my brothers a copy of sean's book for
christmas
oh snap looks like you're gonna be a
main character in the book real soon
a main character i mean i'll make you
the damn villain i don't care
the villain you could be well you could
be in the you could be in the alpha
program if you want i mean
you can do whatever you want be co-opted
by chinese spies but he doesn't know it
i mean you could be you could be an
alpha informant
no it would have to be like uh uh what
do you want you want to be a spy
no like maybe maybe not a spy but maybe
someone who provides like
you know intel right so yeah human
source a human source yeah yeah yeah so
it's like
you know we got a guy oh my god that
would totally work with with your with
your persona is like a vice reporter
yeah a guy who knows a bunch of people
oh dude i already got it
i already got a story arc for you it's
already done i already got it when you
got the questions i need answers to
you got to come on tim castrol podcast
we have too many people come in and out
of this place you know i hear secrets
you
whisper exactly he's part of the
illuminati now exactly that's true
exactly oh yeah i mean that that would
be
if if this audience gets it puts that
book on the on the best seller list
that would be insane that would be crazy
you just have a stink bug laying on your
shirt i think tim
where oh there he is oh yeah she's
flying around ah their little clumsy
things are kind of funny i like them
all right let's see and repeat says did
sean just say if the leaders tell the
police
to not enforce unconstitutional orders
really
did the police take an oath to uphold
the constitution or an oath to be
mindless order followers shaking my head
there's an oath to uh uphold the
constitution
and many of them are just mindlessly
following orders
well what i i was just saying that you
know it's
the police have been put in in very
tough positions because
you know they also part of their oath is
to protect and serve and they and they
believe in the middle of a pan
in the midst of this pandemic that they
really are protecting people's lives by
keeping them socially distantly i'm
trying
they're in a tough spot uh but but but i
i say
always fall back on what is
constitutional and what is not like the
you the government cannot tell you what
you have to wear in your own home the
government cannot tell you how many
people you can have in your own home the
government cannot tell you that you're
not allowed to make a living for your
family
yeah the gov so fall back on the
constitution
and let it be our guide in times of
crisis
because that is our shield the
constitution protects all of us from
authoritarian government overreach
democrat republican
or independent otherwise jamie arzola
says tim poole is the reincarnation of
hunter s thompson
i don't think so because he was like
crazy on drugs
but not in the beginning who's who is
that
i don't know who this is are you sure
are you being serious
oh yeah i know who he is of course he's
a writer that
i don't know who he went and uh took a
bunch of drugs with his lawyers who
drove across the country
yeah did uh fear and loathing in las
vegas
i didn't know that but uh jamie also
says shout out to the united states
marine corps
semper fi there you go yeah he was uh uh
just because he there's a bill murray
movie i don't know i assumed you
probably would have seen it
fear and loathing yeah well yeah of
course i know that johnny that plays
hunter
i didn't know that well there you you go
he's pretty prolific writer
the dutch master says i've never been to
a protest before but i am 35 and have
been politically active since 16. i'm
flying to dc from seattle to participate
in the protest
wow it's going to get spicy
tom says alpha project the pool identity
oh benjamin says tim you should
should live stream the january 6 boots
on the boots in the ground i'd love to
meet you
so we were actually thinking about do
going to dc
for the sixth event and doing the show
from
the production van or whatever but the
internet's gonna be down because there's
gonna be too many people
that's why we can't do it unless we had
a satellite dish but oh we don't have
that so
let's see dt whiz says where do 10
million protesters use the bat use the
restroom
yeah and that's the big challenge you
know the answer to that titan tech 90
says i bought all of his books looks
like tim poole is going to be a main
character of a book yes
well specifically first of all i was i
can't that would be insane
i i mean i didn't even that people are
actually going to buy your book well of
course i'll buy your book
[Laughter]
no i'm just saying it's very very
difficult to get a fiction book on the
bestseller list
and but it it's amazing your audience is
is awesome i mean
all right on yeah good compliment from
sean parnell to all you guys watching it
i mean seriously every time i come on
the show i mean
yeah i hear from hundreds of people who
watch you and i i think what's
interesting tim is that like
in this in in times of sort of universal
deceit people
seek truth and have a craving for truth
i think your show
is is one of the shows that they turn to
in this time and and so
i i gotta point out again when alex is
on the show and he said
i want you to come on my show and i was
like i'm probably not going to do it
people were like they expected me to be
polite and just like
alex still have a show yeah yeah yeah
video he's doing really well with it
actually
he has his own website his own so like i
checked out banned
video a while ago it's where he has his
own he basically cloned youtube
and he gets good he gets a good
viewership i mean the dude clearly is
still doing well for himself
yeah but i wasn't trying to really i
don't really know anything i i've never
watched any of his
any of his stuff but yeah i mean to be
honest i've only seen a lot of the clips
but i've only seen him driving through
an mrap screaming out of a megaphone
that's literally like all i know from
alex jones
the point was the point is i'm not
trying to be mean to him by saying like
i don't know i probably won't do it
because
i work nonstop so when you say like you
can read my books i'm not gonna lie to
you
i could i'm not going to do it well i
mean that doesn't surprise me if you're
trying to be mean though
i i mean i'll rate this one for sure
like definitely that that one
really you know it's intriguing i mean i
don't i don't take offense to it at all
like
most you know i it's like i i love
reading i've read
we have probably like two how many books
were probably like a thousand
yeah easy yeah people send us books like
crazy
and the best part is we get a lot of
manifestos so i have a p.o box
at uh timcast.com donate and
we get manifestos all the time and i
feel like
that this this bodes well for
of a character in a fiction book oh my
god and my mind is already like going
crazy
crazy i got one that was probably like
300 pages once yeah and i'm like i could
never read this i
like you know could you imagine if you
get a manifesto in this story
and the and the manifesto is actually
like the diary of a guy involved in some
crazy terrorist plot that all of a
sudden now the alpha program has to step
in
implicates certain government
individuals that are infiltrated by the
ccp
yes i know see you're already there i
can tell you're already with it
all right let's see let's do uh let's do
a couple more super chats here
nathan nat says in response to the
marine shout out raw
there you go there you go semper fi
robocheese that says hi tim love the
show oh jesus
i love cheez-its please they're they're
just delighted
all right he says please add when you
when you live on different time zones so
when you're live on different time zones
so people like me who move a lot could
find it easier
and would also love to listen live it is
8 p.m eastern monday through friday
sean hollywood says trump to compel
scotus to intervene how
mike pence to ignore contested state
this will trigger house to elect trump
biden will go to scotus to contest
cases will be reviewed on merit
i don't think i think there's no
political willpower
like you have you have three trump
appointees who are just like can i tell
you
look i've got to be careful because i've
got a case in front of the supreme court
now
um and i i want to go into this saying
that i i absolutely respect the the
justices on that court and whatever
verdict they would come to in my case
tim but
i do think that the supreme court is
also an inherently political body
yep and i do think that part of some of
the justices are making the calculation
and again i i'm just it's just
speculation i can't stress that enough
that they're saying
they want to be able to turn around to a
biden administration and say look like
we did we didn't roll on this stuff
there's no need to pack the institution
of the supreme court yeah
oh my god they think they're well i mean
they're trying to preserve the
institution
what they're doing is they're saying
elections every four years but the
institution of the supreme court
is sacrosanct so they basically think
they're gonna that even if they did rule
in favor of trump they'd still lose
so their best bet is to you know play
politics
beg to biden not to or the democrats not
to disrupt the court wow
we need a robot to be the secretary i i
think it's re i i also think that if
you're a justice i think that that's
probably i think that that's reasonable
i mean i don't i don't i'm i'm not
saying i
want them to take up my case on the
merits i think it's a strong case i
think act 7
what violates the state constitution
violates the federal constitution the
federal government delegates powers to
the states to conduct elections as
long as the states run elections in
accordance with their state constitution
that did not happen on a number of
different levels in the state of
pennsylvania
the case is strong the supreme court
should take it up
um but it's it's an explosive case
there's a constitutional crisis but also
let's not forget that the supreme court
is an inherently political body
and and bureaucracies in general protect
themselves
you know and and i think the justices
are seeking to protect the institution
of the supreme court i mean
that has to be part of their calculus
yeah well sean thanks for coming and
hanging out
oh absolutely merry christmas hey merry
christmas to you guys too thanks for
having me we have to say happy holidays
no uh merry merry christmas no we don't
merry christmas monica what else is
there this time
yeah happy holidays to you and yours
yeah happy holidays yeah merry christmas
merry christmas merry christmas thanks
for having me again i i
you know i love you i know people who
don't celebrate christmas who were like
when i was younger they're like i don't
understand why
they even say happy holidays like who
cares like merry christmas whatever what
would jesus do
if he was around today with the internet
merry christmas something like this
make a show about christ right make sure
to follow me on twitter instagram parlor
at
tim cast my other youtube channels can
be found at youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comtimcastnews
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm so make sure you come hang
out tomorrow because we have people
coming to hang out tomorrow
and uh also we're gonna we're gonna if
you guys want to
get sean parnell's book one true patriot
is the right one right that's the new
one yeah
one true patriot on the best seller list
you only need to sell what a few
thousand
i think it i think a few thousand copies
gets you on the list i mean it's
it's i know you say only but that's
really that's really difficult well
because
i hear stories about like 500 000 copies
sold well i mean if you want to make
number one
on the fiction list you got to sell 500
i mean some it depends on who's on the
list i mean sometimes it's 5
000 copies sometimes it's 10. uh but i
think five six thousand copies gives you
a good shot to get
dust but sean parnell himself is one
true patriot and he's got a book why
thank you i see what you did there tim
and i like it i love it uh do you want
to mention your social media
oh yeah i'm at sean parneau usa on
twitter and on parlor
and you can follow me on on facebook and
instagram
he very very conveniently got me all of
these books for christmas just so open
up for them tim you asked for them let's
not leave that out for your audience you
asked for them you said no for sure
dude sign them and they're signed oh
they are where is the best place to buy
them
oh you can get them anywhere books are
sold i mean and there are audio books
out there as well i mean
um i mean it it's it's really kind of
cool to be able to
write uh pretty much money yeah well
when this makes the best sellers i'm
gonna be like
i'm gonna find them on ebay tomorrow
ebay profile
no right on right on uh anything else
you want to promote and we'll
no man i i i really do appreciate as as
you as usual tim like you're great to me
and and
you get yeah i love
yeah i love the opening conversation
about your military service too because
you know getting into that school and
that's why i'll i definitely will start
reading
platoon because this to me is like you
know i've been
in uh civil unrest and civil conflict
like i don't whatever you'd call a
revolution in egypt was like the the
peak of the craziness
but uh you know so reading this and
reading more about the actual
the full-blown conflict that book is is
not it's a studiously nonpartisan book
it's just about
close infantry combat and a year and a
half
the media really fed us like a kind of a
storybook
not like hey no violence really even
happened during the war we just went in
and made sure everyone was safe
it's not it's funny that you say that
because when we went to afghanistan
i mean we thought we were going into a
stability and support operation and it
we could not have been more wrong
it was intense close infantry combat
for 16 months and it's all in that book
smash that like button everybody there
subscribe share yeah
smash the like button we have a graphic
now so you need to get reverb with it
smash the like button button
button uh you can also follow uh ian
yes follow me guys at ian crossland i
want to give a special shout out to
jesus christ because
we were talking a lot about christmas
named after him christ you know the
anointed one
he may not be the only prophet but uh he
spoke the truth
to power if he'd been a little smarter
or maybe had better technology they
might not have found him and
cut his head off sold out bro yeah his
buddy sold him out he relied
he pieces of silver but let's see what
if we could live like jesus and do it
right this time
and how many and we and and i'll say
this because i'll be i'll be
controversial especially with you here
to the police officers who are being
told to enforce
unconstitutional or even outright
illegal uh uh
edict in exchange for 30 pieces of
silver
you must reject it yeah you can also
follow uh
sour patch lids you can sour patch lids
l-i-d-s
i do she's a good follow oh thank you i
appreciate that spicy memes
interesting takes right on yes the best
we will be back
tomorrow so make sure you smash that
like button on your way out
and thanks for hanging everybody we will
we'll see you tomorrow at 8pm
bye guys
you